la séance est ouverte
en cette journée internationale des
infirmières et des infirmiers
je souhaite rendre un hommage
particulier à ces femmes et à ces hommes
qui oeuvrent chaque jour pour la santé
de nos concitoyens parfois au péril de
la leur leurs engagements exemplaires
aux côtés de l'ensemble des personnels
de santé nous oblige
d'autant plus qu'ils sont en première
ligne dans la crise sanitaire sans
précédent à laquelle nous faisons face
jeu vaut aujourd'hui les assurés de la
reconnaissance de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement je vous rappelle les règles
dérogatoires d'organisation de nos
séances de questions en raison de la
crise sanitaire 150 députés peuvent à
partir de cette semaine
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils soient tous là
se réunir dans l'hémicycle selon une
répartition proportionnelle aux
effectifs des groupes
par ailleurs les règles d'organisation
de notre science reprennent celles qui
ont été appliqués la semaine dernière
enfin des règles de sanitaires continue
naturellement à s'appliquer nettoyage
des micros en cours de séance les
orateurs sont invités à ne pas poser les
mains sur les micro et utiliser des
micros différents respect des distances
entre les participants entrée et sortie
échelonnée
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du coït
19 en général et notamment sur le thème
de la santé
la parole est à madame chloriers claudia
rouault par bah merci monsieur le
président la question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre je tiens tout d'abord à
rendre un hommage appuyé aux maires et
élus locaux pour leur engagement et leur
mobilisation dans la gestion de la crise
du coronavirus aux côtés des services de
l'état avec agilité réactivité les
communes ont agi pour protéger la
population et assurer la continuité du
service public de la distribution de
masques à la réouverture des écoles
alors que la france est engagée dans un
déconfinement progressif il est
nécessaire de mener à terme le processus
démocratique des élections municipales
et communautaires
à l'issue du premier tour du scrutin le
15 mars dernier plus de 30 mille
communes ont un conseil municipal est
lui au complet dans le respect des
précautions sanitaires leur installation
rapide est souhaitable pour y élire les
exécutifs et engager les projets de
mandature suite à l'avis du conseil
scientifique le gouvernement vient de
donner son feu vert
je salue cette décision en sachant que
les nouveaux élus sont dans la tente de
précisions
sur le calendrier d'installation des
conseils municipaux c'est d'autant plus
important que les communes et les
intercommunalités seront un fer de lance
de la relance de notre économie
or la capacité de nos collectivités à
investir ne pourra pas se faire sans
installer les conseils renouveler dans
toutes les communes et intercommunalités
du pays
c'est un enjeu majeur pour le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics
par ailleurs l'incertitude persiste pour
près de 5000 communes dans lequel un
second tour doit être organisé un
scénario vise à organiser organisé ce
second tour avant l'été si la vie
économique scolaire et sociale reprend
progressivement son cours
la vie démocratique ne peut rester en
suspens en cas de maîtrise de l'épidémie
dans le strict respect des consignes
sanitaires et cet objectif peut être te
nappe par tous ces possibles dont
l'impossibilité de tenir ces élections
avant l'été pour des raisons sanitaires
les résultats du premier tour devrait
être sanctuarisé d'une part dans le
respect du vote des électeurs et d'autre
part dans la crainte d'une raréfaction
de l'offre démocratique à ce titre de
sérieuses difficultés remercier ses
collègues
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés même la députée
vous m'interrogez sur la question
essentielle de du respect de la
démocratie dans une période de crise
sanitaire
comme vous je suis extrêmement attachée
au fait que alors même que nos vies ont
été comme contrainte est presque empêché
à certains égards pendant cette période
de confinement les institutions au
premier rang desquels le parlement et
l'ensemble des institutions
démocratiques puise puissent suivre
leurs cours et remplir leur office de
façon à ce que crise sanitaire ne rime
pas avec crise démocratique
vous savez madame la députée qu'il vous
a fallu parce que l'épidémie accéléré
renoncé à tenir dans les conditions qui
était prévu le deuxième tour des
élections municipales elle devait être
il devait avoir lieu
le 22 mars mémoire le parlement a été
saisi de cette question évidemment se
poser dans des termes jamais rencontré
et il a après discussion intelligemment
prévu une procédure qui permet ou qui
impose plus exactement au gouvernement
de faire un rapport au plus tard le 23
mai afin de décider si oui ou non les
élections peuvent se tenir le deuxième
tour des élections peuvent se tenir peut
se tenir à la fin du mois de juin et si
oui ou non on peut installer ce des
conseils municipaux qui ont été élus au
terme du premier tour
nous ne pourrons prendre cette décision
qu'au regard des avis donnés par les
scientifiques qui nous diront c'est
possible et le cas échéant dans quelles
conditions où ça semble délicat mais si
on fait ceci peut-être que ce sera
voilà on doit évidemment écouter ce
qu'auront à dire les scientifiques mais
ce ne sont pas les scientifiques qui
décide c'est évidemment le pouvoir
politique détenu par des élus
responsables devant la représentation
nationale qui peut lui seul prendre la
décision
j'ai indiqué à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat que j'avais d'ores et déjà
saisi le comité des scientifiques afin
qu'il nous indique s'il était possible
selon lui de procéder à l'installation
rapide des conseils municipaux élus dès
le premier tour
vous le savez il a rendu son avis son
avis est favorable ce qui ne nous
surprend guère puisque dès lors que nous
avons commencé le déconfinement il
paraît possible dans trente mille des
communes sur les 35 mille que compte
notre pays
d'installer les conseils municipaux
lesquels sont le plus souvent composé de
15 membres au maximum
on doit donc grâce aux dispositions qui
ont été prévues par la loi qui prévoit
des méthodes de calcul du quorum plus
favorable qui prévoit la possibilité de
porter deux pouvoirs et par un seul être
en mesure d'organiser dans de bonnes
conditions
l'installation des conseils municipaux
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
conformément à l'avis
comité des scientifiques et sur le
rapport adressé à monsieur le président
de l'assemblée nationale et monsieur le
président du sénat par le ministre de
l'intérieur nous prenons la décision et
nous avons pris la décision de procéder
à l'installation des conseils municipaux
des conseils municipaux élus
complètement au premier tour peut-être
un mot de calendrier car autant être
précis j'ai transmis ce matin 12 mai aux
présidents des deux assemblées je les
dis le rapport du gouvernement
le décret qui prévoit l'installation de
ces conseils municipaux sera pris enfin
sera publié le vendredi 15 mai il fixera
la date d'entrée en fonction des
conseillers municipaux et communautaires
le lundi 18 mai
conformément à la loi du 23 mars la
première réunion du conseil municipal
qui permettra notamment d'élire le maire
et ses adjoints jeudi notamment d'élire
le maire et ses adjoints se tiendra dans
les cinq à dix jours après la date
d'entrée en fonction des conseillers
municipaux soit entre le samedi 23 mai
et le jeudi 28 mai autrement dit
mesdames et messieurs les députés au
plus tard le jeudi 28 mai trente mille
des 35000 communes françaises auront un
conseil municipal installé et un maire
et des adjoints élus dans les conditions
normales et je pense que nous pouvons
tous nous en féliciter restera
restera restera la question du deuxième
tour des élections municipales
le comité scientifique se prononcera sur
l'appréciation qu'ils portent au regard
de ses connaissances au moment où il
doit se prononcer et je crois que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler il est
encore un peu tôt pour tirer toutes les
conséquences d'un avis dont nous ne
disposons pas merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole et à madame
frédérique dumas merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
hier le conseil constitutionnel a
censuré plusieurs dispositions de la loi
de prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
il vous a ainsi contraint ce que le juge
donne obligatoirement son autorisation
pour toute décision du préfet de mise en
cartons run
pourtant notre groupe vous avez proposé
avec mon collègue charles de courson un
amendement allant précisément dans ce
sens la tension est quand allez vous
écouter et surtout entendre cette
volonté de remettre en cause la place du
juge concernant des mesures
attentatoires aux libertés publiques et
malheureusement récurrente
vous avez été sanctionné hier sur ce
point dans la loi dite anti casseurs
voulez aujourd'hui sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
vous le serez sans doute demain sur la
loi contre la haine sur internet que
vous vous apprêtez à voter soit il
s'agit d'une volonté systématique et
délibérée de remettre en cause ce qui
fonde notre droit depuis deux siècles et
c'est grave soit il s'agit de
précipitation et c'est grave aussi le
principe de la place du juge en amont et
non en aval de va être votre boussole
il n'est pas négociable cette décision
illustre par ailleurs le manque
d'anticipation
le confinement réduit est mis à profit
pour 4 sa sortie le pays est davantage
la capacité de répondre à la menace
sanitaire alors le président de
république a rendu cet objectif presque
inatteignable en donnant le 13 avril une
date de début des travaux le 11 mai dans
la vraie vie pour n'importe quel
chantier cela ne fonctionne pas de ce
fait nous n'atteindrons pas les 700
mille tests hebdomadaires annoncée par
ailleurs les brigades sanitaire
quelqu'un telles qu'elles nous sont
présentés sont quant à elles bien
éloigné de l'expérience pilote du
professeur piarroux à la pitié
salpêtrière cette expérience remettait
l'humain au coeur du dispositif et
nécessité sur le terrain des dizaines de
milliers de personnes formées pour
accompagner les personnes contaminées
par ailleurs il vous appartient que des
efforts supplémentaires soient fournis
pour que les mesures de distanciation
dans les réseaux de transport puissent
être plus facilement respecter
aussi ma question est simple pourquoi
les services de transport du quotidien
ne fonctionne pas à 100 % de leurs
capacités notamment à la ratp
pouvez vous nous donner d'or une réponse
de manière précise à cette question car
cela aurait une double vertu avoir des
transports publics moins remplie car
plus nombreux et permettent à des
travailleurs notamment de la ratp
actuellement en chômage partiel de
toucher de nouveau leur plein salaire
merci la parole est à monsieur olivier
véran ministre des solidarités de la
santé merci madame la députée dumas pour
votre question plein d'encouragements
qui nous vont droit au coeur à l'heure
où nous avons décidé de lever
progressivement les conditions du
confinement pour permettre aux français
de retrouver une vie familiale sociale
économique qui leur a beaucoup manqué
j'ai compris à travers votre question
que les choses n'étaient pas simples
nous n'avons jamais eu la prétention de
dire qu'elles le seraient néanmoins
sachez que nous mettons tout en oeuvre
pour assurer la sécurité des français je
crois que cela ce désir nous le
partageons il beaucoup de questions de
votre question je ne vous parlerais pas
dans des tailles de la vie rendues par
le conseil constitionnel systech qui ne
me semble qu'il s'agit éventuellement
d'ajustement sur la place du juge est
certainement pas une remise en question
sur la garantie des libertés
j'ai passé ici avec vous madame et
messieurs les députés deux jours au
cours desquels nous avons abondamment
débattues largement débattue vous avez
amélioré ce texte vous l'avez enrichi
vous l'avez préciser les sénateurs
l'avaient fait à leur tour les jours
précédents ce qui nous a permis d'avoir
un rendu du conseil constitutionnel qui
est totalement conforme à ce que nous
avions prévu de faire pour lever le
confinement dans notre pays notamment
l'article 6 a été validé ce qui est
important ce qui va nous permettre
d'avoir les outils numériques dont nous
avons besoin pour pouvoir non seulement
madame la députée faire les 700 mille
tests être en mesure de faire 7 7 de ses
700 mille tonnes par semaine mais
surtout de faire en sorte qu'un test
réalisé puissent bénéficier à tout le
monde dans toute la filière de soins
dans toute la chaîne de soins pour
casser les chaînes de contamination et
protéger les français
les conditions de reprise des transports
comme la députée avec l'attribution du
masque nous étions engagés
c'est fait c'est fait et hier je crois
que nous pouvons constater
collectivement qu'hormis des
rassemblements qui ont pu être observés
et là et qui justifie à mon sens la
nécessité de garder fermée parcs et
jardins dans les zones rouges du
territoire où le cirque le virus circule
de plus les choses se sont déroulées
dans des conditions à la fois de calme
de gravité de sérieux considérant que
les français ont parfaitement compris
que l'épidémie n'était pas derrière nous
et qu'il fallait d'être extrêmement
prudent dans la marche vers le
déconfinement je vous remercie encore la
parole est à monsieur pierre cordier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je ne veux pas
polémiquer cet après midi mais vous
devez comprendre la colère de nos
compatriotes qui viennent de vivre une
période très difficile une période où de
nombreux citoyens se sont dévoués corps
et âme pour d'autres je veux avoir une
pensée pour tous ces gens de france qui
ont perdu un être cher je veux avoir une
pensée pour celles et ceux qui tous les
jours on sauver des vies ont pris des
risques au péril de leur propre vie
on sait aujourd'hui monsieur le premier
ministre que 600 millions de masques ont
été détruits à tort alors qu'ils
auraient pu servir à protéger les
pharmaciens et soignants les
ambulanciers commerçants les pompiers
enseignants
la liste est longue votre ministre a
affirmé ici avoir sauvé 19 millions de
ses 600 millions de masques détruit par
erreur
monsieur le premier ministre qui a signé
les bons de destruction de ces masques
vous n'échapperez pas à votre
responsabilité dans cette affaire qui
est une affaire d'état personne ne sera
amnistié de ses propres fautes
politiques et hauts fonctionnaires
vous devez la vérité aux français qui
nous écoutent le président emmanuel
macron averti de cette pandémie dès
décembre 2019 devra lui aussi assumer
ses responsabilités nous dire pourquoi
les mesures prises ont été huit semaines
après les députés sont élus monsieur le
premier ministre pour contrôler votre
action compter sur le groupe des
républicains pour assumer cette
responsabilité avec rigueur ténacité et
objectivité
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est simple qui a signé ses bons de
destruction des masques
nous attendons une réponse claire je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député qu'est ce que ce sera quand vous
polémique créée par lancé le député mais
je vous souhaite j'espère être plus
précis en commission denquête que vous
l'avez été dans votre question est les
parts dans votre question
bourré au mieux d'erreur au mieux
d'erreur mais j'imagine que ce ne sont
que des erreurs on parle ici de quoi on
parle de masques destinés à protéger les
soignants masques chirurgicaux masques
ffp2 datant du début des années 2000
pour la plupart de 2003 non pourvus de
date de péremption à l'époque ça ne se
faisait pas en tout cas sur les masques
qui avait été acheté je n'étais pas là
j'étais très loin de mystère sur ses
masques une enquête a été demandée en
2017 par le directeur général de la
santé à cette recette à santé publique
france l'organisme chargé de stocker ses
masques santé publique france a fait
examiner ces masques par la dg en
parlant 16 par toutes les autorités qui
sont allés regarder les capacités d'une
part de filtration du masque sa part si
ça protège du virus et de respirabilité
du masque pour savoir si le masque peut
être portée la sentence est tombée en
2018 ces masques n'était plus en état de
protéger les soignants
c'était déjà arrivé les années
précédentes ça arrivera encore monsieur
le député dès lors un bon destruction a
été donnée par la direction générale de
la santé pour ne pas garder des masques
périmés hors d'usagé qu'on ne pouvait
pas utiliser pour des soignants ces
masques ont commencé à être détruit
progressivement jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2019 qui sont des masques qui ne
pouvait pas répondre aux normes
soignants 200 et quelques millions de
ces masses ont été détruits mais comme
des nombreuses boîtes de médicaments
sont détruites également par les
autorités de santé lorsqu'ils sont
périmés ça peut arriver que les
matériaux soient périmés en 2020 en mars
j'ai demandé aux autorités au même que
celle qui avait statué sur la qualité de
ces masques de vérifier si ces masques
qui ne sont pas disponibles pour les
soignants pouvait être disponible pour
le grand public
une partie de ces masques 80 millions
environ ont pu être récupérées non pas
pour des soignants parce qu'il ne
filtrait pas assez et que leur qualité
n'était pas garanti mais ont pu être
utilisés pour le grand public le reste
de ces masses monsieur le député
je vous le confirme sera détruit parce
que ce sont des masques qui ne protège
pas qui ne sont pas respirable et qu'on
ne peut prendre que les soignants ni
même la population générale
merci monsieur le ministre c'est cordier
monsieur porlier
oui monsieur monsieur le ministre benoît
valait ancien directeur général de la
santé affirme que les masques détruit
auraient pu être utilisés je le cite
ils peuvent être utilisés même les skis
mais lorsqu'il pardon sont anciens
qu'ils conservent leur propriété voilà
leur propriété et c'était le cas pour
une grosse partie de ces masques
monsieur le ministre et vous le savez
très bien merci monsieur le député la
parole est à madame brigitte bourguignon
ce de la parole mme la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la santé qui les
interviennent à l'hôpital en ville dans
les ehpad dans nos établissements
accueillant des perses des personnes en
situation de handicap ou dans les
services à domicile
les personnels soignants font face avec
un courage exceptionnel à l'épidémie que
notre pays connaît sans eux nous
n'aurions jamais gagné cette première
bataille et je tiens aujourd'hui au nom
de la représentation nationale à les en
remercier encore la nation toute entière
est derrière eux reconnaissante
elle leur rend hommage chaque jour
depuis près de deux mois
lors de son déplacement à mulhouse le 25
mars dernier le président de la
république a demandé au gouvernement
d'apporter une réponse claire et forte
de court terme sous forme d'une prime
exceptionnelle pour l'ensemble de ses
engagés en première ligne à l'issue de
cette crise nous aurons le devoir de
faire plus pour eux et cela passera très
concrètement par la revalorisation des
carrières en présence du premier
ministre vous avez eu l'occasion de
préciser le montant et les modalités de
la prime qui sera versée au personnel
hospitalier ainsi qu'au personnel des
ehpad dans les prochaines semaines vous
avez également annoncé l'octroi d'une
prime au personnel des services d aide à
domicile
de nombreux établissements qui assurent
la protection des personnes âgées et des
personnes en situation de handicap
je pense en particulier aux aides à
domicile aux auxiliaires de vie sans
lesquelles les mesures de confinement à
domicile de nos coûts
patriotes les plus fragiles aurait été
impossible car elle reste bien souvent
le seul lien avec l'extérieur pour les 5
millions de personnes âgées handicapées
qui vivent seules chez elles dans notre
pays
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
confirmer que le montant et les
modalités de cette prime seront
identiques à celles attribuées aux
personnels des ehpad
quel est l'état d'avancement de vos
échanges avec les conseils
départementaux pour en assurer le
financement
chevaux merci merci madame la présidente
la parole à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci pour votre question madame la
présidente brigitte bourguignon
ce matin je me suis rendu du côté dans
le val de marne pour aller visiter un
ehpad et pour rencontrer également un
couple de personnes âgées qui est resté
à domicile et qui a bénéficié du soutien
indispensable vital même dead à domicile
j'ai rencontré une aide à domicile qui
me racontait les difficultés inhérentes
à sa profession et à l'exercice de ses
missions dans la période qui s'est
écoulée
je vous rejoins donc sur l'objectif il
faut pouvoir valoriser ce qui a été fait
de manière admirable par des personnes
sans qui les personnes âgées ou les
personnes en situation de handicap
toutes les personnes vulnérables qui
sont restées chez elles pendant des
semaines n'aurait pu le faire dans les
mêmes conditions et si aujourd'hui c'est
la journée internationale des infirmiers
et je remercie monsieur le président de
l'assemblée nationale de l'avoir
souligné si brillamment
moi je veux aussi qu'on ait cette pensée
cet hommage rendu à l'ensemble des
personnes c'est indispensable dans la
république celles et ceux qui permettent
à nos enfants d'aller à l'école à nos
grands parents ou à nos parents d'être
protégé et même chez eux
toutes ces personnes qu'on ne voit pas
suffisamment au quotidien mais qui sont
devenus tellement tellement visible est
tellement indispensable regarde tous
depuis le début de cette crise
épidémique
une prime vous l'avez dit a été annoncée
par le premier ministre pour tout le
personnel des ehpad ainsi que pour les
siyad les services infirmiers à domicile
parce que le financement dépend au moins
pour partie de l'assurance maladie et
donc il était possible pour
l'assurance-maladie de faire ce geste je
le rappelle 1500 euros de prime
défiscalisé désocialisés que toucheront
tous les personnels des ehpad dans 40
départements français qui ont vu de très
près le virus et de manière très intense
et tous les autres toucheront quand même
1000 euros par mois 1000 euros par mois
dans l'ensemble des ehpad pour les
personnels des deux domiciles et les
aides à domicile nous travaillons avec
les départements c'est leur compétence
départementale
le président de l'association des
départements de france dominique
bussereau avec lequel je travaille très
bien et très régulièrement et je l'en
remercie mme a déclaré son souhait que
les départements puces à leur tour
intervenir
nous travaillons à leur côté pour
arriver à cet objectif et j'espère que
votre demande sera entendue dans les
plus brefs délais merci monsieur le
ministre la parole et à monsieur
françois cornut-gentille
merci monsieur le président aujourd'hui
monsieur le premier ministre tout le
monde prépare l'après qu'ovide chacun a
ses priorités parmi les plus évoqués il
y à la croissance verte l'hôpital et la
santé la défense de nos industries où le
soutien au pouvoir d'achat
j'ajoute que la lutte contre le chômage
s'imposera malheureusement d'elle-même
le problème quand tout est prioritaire
c'est qu'il n'ya plus priorité si dans
ce contexte monsieur le premier ministre
que je voudrais vous interroger sur la
place que vous comptez accordé à notre
effort de défense
votre ministre des armées madame par lee
a déclaré hier devant notre commission
de la défense
quel était pour sa part convaincu de son
caractère réellement prioritaire tant au
regard de l'intérêt de nos industries
que la situation internationale
je voudrais savoir monsieur le premier
ministre si vous partagez cette
conviction et surtout si tel était le
cas si vous en tirer toutes les
conséquences vous sentirez bien que des
considérations générales qui n'engagent
que ceux qui y croient ne permettrait
pas d'éclairer réellement la
représentation nationale sur cet
important sujet
aussi je crois qu'il serait utile à tous
que vous puissiez répondre nettement aux
deux questions suivantes
la première consiste à vous demander si
pour mesurer notre effort de défense
votre gouvernement continuera à
raisonner en valeur absolue à partir du
montant de crédits inscrits à la loi de
programmation militaire ou s'il adoptera
le standard de l'otan soit 2% du pib
cette seconde option serait en effet
lourde de conséquences avec une baisse
du pib estimé à 8%
la seconde question concerne le budget
2021 qui doit bénéficier d'une hausse de
1 milliard 7,2 crédit dans la situation
nouvelle où nous nous trouvons estimez
vous que cet engagement sera
difficilement atteignable qu'il doit
être maintenue coûte que coûte ou qu'il
faut même procédé un effort
supplémentaire notamment pour celles du
soutenir nos industries stratégiques
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le poème monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous m'interrogez sur
l'effort de défense que la france doit
consentir en pesant de questions
précises
j'allais dire importante sur le plan
politique mais quasiment technique
la référence à 12% de pib ou à la valeur
absolue c'est vous et moi ça nous
passionne peut-être avant de répondre à
votre question un mot qui me semble plus
important encore est ce que le monde
dans lequel nous vivons est tel qu'il
semble se dessiner dans les mois et dans
les années qui viennent car vous savez
que s'agissant de la défense il faut
raisonner en termes d'années peut-être
même parfois de dizaines d'années est ce
que le monde qui vient est un monde plus
tranquille moins risqué plus pacifié je
ne crois pas
je le déplore d'ailleurs ce serait
tellement formidable d'imaginer que nous
allons devoir nous reconstruire après
cette crise sanitaire dans un monde qui
aurait si profondément changé que les
ambitions territoriales les compétitions
armés les risques géopolitiques aurait
disparu ce serait formidable mais
malheureusement je ne crois pas que ce
soit le monde dans lequel nous vivons
autrement dit tout ce qui est à
l'origine du choix formulée par le
président de la république au moment de
la campagne électorale et qui s'est
traduit année après année par des
décisions fortes budgétaire opérationnel
de faire revenir le budget de la france
à un niveau raisonnable en matière
d'efforts de défense après qu'il ait si
longtemps étaient tenues si bas cet
effort de défense monsieur le député
aucune des raisons qui ont prévalu au
choix du président ne se trouve
aujourd'hui modifiée et je pense que on
peut partir de ce point là qui ne me
paraît pas faire l'objet de débats très
longs pour construire la suite
la suite c'est comment est ce que nous
allons construire le budget 2021
monsieur le député
quelque chose me dit que ça va être un
exercice intéressant et je le dis en
faisant usage d'une litote pour le coup
intéressant parce qu'évidemment la
situation financière les enjeux
collectifs pas simplement matière de
défense en matière de santé matière
d'éducation en matière d'infrastructures
la nécessité de faire repartir notre
économie notre industrie nos services la
nécessité de construire notre sécurité
demain tout cela à ce devoir être
tranchée dans un cadre profondément
impactés par l'absence de recettes d'un
côté l'augmentation des dépenses de
l'autre c'est une équation qui ne va pas
être exactement facile de résoudre
et pourtant il va nous falloir le faire
et nous allons faire collectivement dans
le cadre de choix politiques qui
n'auront rien de discret et tous de
public mais le moment de la construction
du budget 2021 n'est pas encore venu non
plus d'ailleurs que le moment de sa
discussion
il appartiendra évidemment à la
représenter à la représentation
nationale de se prononcer
le sujet vous comprenez bien de ma
réponse que je considère le gouvernement
considère que l'impératif de défense
reste un impératif de premier rang et
que tous ceux qui penseraient le
contraire se verrait le moment venu
exposer à des risques qu aucun d'entre
nous n'a envie de voir se réaliser
michel fanget merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre je tiens en prie allah
bien sûr à cette question rendre hommage
appuyé et sincère à toutes ces femmes et
tous ces hommes qui se sont mobilisés et
qui sont toujours au front jour et nuit
pour nous soigner nous protéger et pour
éviter que la france ne sombre je pense
aussi à toutes ces familles durement
impactés par cette pandémie équipe de
plus vives parfois leur deuil dans des
conditions particulièrement éprouvantes
en ma qualité de médecin cardiologue
j'apporte bien sûr mon soutien à toutes
les mesures gouvernementales mises en
place pour lutter contre cette pandémie
et réduire de façon drastique la
propagation du virus
conjugué à la discipline de nos
concitoyens qui ont accepté d'y fils
difficile confinement à l'instar des 34
maladie à déclaration obligatoire
les professionnels de santé ont
désormais l'obligation de transmettre
contre rémunération l'identité des
patients atteints du coït 19 de leurs
proches de tous leurs contacts pour les
confier à une brigade sanitaire
je comprends bien sûr la finalité d'un
tel dispositif pour nous prévenir nous
protéger et prévenir une deuxième vague
qui imposerait un nouveau confinement
mais je dire votre attention sur le
respect impérieux du secret médical dont
la transgression relève de l'éthique
médicale la plus élémentaire
en tant que professionnels de santé je
m'interroge comme bon nombre de mes
confrères sur la fragilisation de la
protection des données médicales
personnelles recueillies par une brigade
composée de personnes habitudes n'ont
habituellement habilité et notamment des
agents de mairie aux deux départements
cet élargissement ouvre la porte à
d'éventuelles dérives telles que non
respect de la vie privée aux usa ces
dernières années plus de 170 millions de
dossiers médicaux
été piraté et susceptibles d'être
exploités par des sociétés d'assurance
des banques voire des employeurs avec
toutes les conséquences néfastes que
l'on peut imaginer
de plus le logiciel de traitement des
données est fourni par le géant
américain microsoft qui aura de fait
accès à l'ensemble de ces informations
dans ces conditions monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous rassurer quant aux
possibles des toits verts l'état
monsieur olivier veyrat au ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le député changer pour votre question
qui porte sur le respect du secret
médical et les conditions d'actions des
personnes on parle de brigade mais avant
tout ce sont des femmes et des hommes
qui travaillent au sein de l'assurance
maladie qui travaillent au sein des
agences régionales de santé ou qui sont
tout simplement médecins de terrain un
médecin de famille et qui vont
participer à cette formidable campagne
indispensable pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
cette campagne qui consiste à assurer le
suivi épidémiologique la protection des
malades
la détermination des personnes cas
contacts potentiels et la protection de
ces cas contacts comme nous l'avons fait
depuis plusieurs semaines dans notre
pays mais que nous nous préparons à
faire peut-être à plus large échelle
si la situation épidémique devait
l'imposer le tout avec l'aide d'outils
numériques à l'instar de l'ensemble des
pays que nous avons pour coutume de cité
en modèle dans cet hémicycle dans la
gestion de crise et dans un strict
respect de la loi puisque la loi a été
examinée abondamment au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale et le conseil
constitutionnel l'a validée
soyez rassuré monsieur le député sur le
fait que tout d'abord lorsque nous
allons rémunérer une consultation
médicale
c'est une consultation médicale longues
complexes qui contiendra d'abord le
diagnostic clinique la prescription du
test la prescription du test à
l'ensemble des cas contactez la
détermination de facteurs de risque de
comorbidité de fragilité la prescription
d'isolement ou de l'a14 end lorsque
c'est nécessaire
l'explication de tout ce qui va avec
désinfection des surfaces en commun etc
etc et ensuite il ya cette question qui
consiste à pousser plus loin la
discussion pour essayer de déterminer
avec la personne désormais malades
quelles sont les personnes qu'elle a pu
contaminer malgré elle les 48 heures
précédant l'apparition des premiers
simples
comme tout cela nécessite aussi du temps
du travail et nous devons le faire pour
vous rassurer sur le secret médical
toutes les garanties ont été apportées
dans la loi et j'en veux pour preuve le
conte le communiqué du conseil national
de l'ordre des médecins qui après avoir
posé un certain nombre de questions
s'est félicité hier d'avoir obtenu des
réponses à l'ensemble de ces questions
à l'instar de ce qui existe pour les
fichiers des affections longue durée ou
pour des arrêts de travail l'assurance
maladie c'est être le garant numérique
et humains de secret médical
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame sabine rubin monsieur le
ministre et l'éducation nationale il ya
deux semaines je vous interrogeait sur
les multiples inquiétudes de la
communauté éducative suscité par vos
annonces de la reprise sur la reprise de
l'école en effet il était précisé
rien ni en matière de mesures sanitaires
ni d'organisation du travail des
enseignants de rythme des élèves ou de
responsabilité des acteurs justes le
volontariat de chacun je vous
conseillait alors de repenser votre
copie en prenant appui sur l'expertisé
de ses acteurs mais vous avez répondu
par l'envoi d'un bottin de règles
sanitaires anxiogène que chacun a dû
mettre en oeuvre en se débrouillant
ainsi tout diffère selon l'académie la
circonscription la vie l'établissement
une reprise non pas tant progressive cas
la carte comme le lycée finalement vous
avez également adressé des
recommandations pédagogique aux
enseignants ils ne vous ont pas attendu
pour cela les habitants qu'elle comble à
faire preuve d'empathie avec les élèves
mais de l'empathie monsieur le ministre
vous n'en n'avez guère à leur égard
comment feront ils pour consoler un
élève de maternelle ampleur rien de
prévu
que feront les avantages pour contenir
les enfants en situation de handicap
qu'il consulte la fiche parachuté hier
après deux mois de silence
alors certes si votre discours
maintenant mentionne l'aspect
psychologique le prendre soin des
enfants ce qui aurait dû guider votre
plan cette bienveillance de circonstance
arrive un peu tard
en réalité votre gestion technocratique
et erratique à 7 de cette reprise à mu
et l'inquiétude des parents une anxiété
permanente et vous voilà contraint de
déclarer de déclarer qu'il est moins
dangereux d'aller à l'école que de
rester ce soir
pour re faire revenir tous les enfants
un récent sondage indique en effet que
plus de 60% des familles ne souhaitent
pas envoyer leurs enfants à l'école et
davantage chez les classes populaires
quelle ironie là encore même votre
objectif de justice sociale se voit
contrarier du mois dans l'idée monsieur
le ministre
évitez les chiffres de satisfait tistes
7 à vous a crié la parole est à monsieur
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
sabine rubin heureusement on peut
retourner sur le terrain et comme
j'étais ce matin
cela m'a mis du baume au coeur et me
permet de faire la différence avec votre
question parce que en effet heureusement
la réalité différente de ce que vous
faites
je vous je vous remercie de ce que du
fait de faire référence à ce que vous
disiez il ya deux semaines on pourrait
faire référence aussi à ce qui vous
disiez il ya deux mois quand nous
entrions dans le confinement
vous vous disiez que nous avions raté
l'enseignement à distance
aujourd'hui il est sondage vous êtes
densité disent que 75 % des parents sont
satisfaits de la façon dont nous l'avons
fait et aujourd'hui où nous déconfit non
parce que c'est une urgence sociale
vous dites qu'il faudrait rester à la
maison votre parti considère qu'il
faudrait rester jusqu'au mois de
septembre si c'est ce que vous dites et
c'est ce que disent vos leaders
c'est à dire que vous prenez ce qu'il ya
de plus antisociale dans votre
département la seine saint denis
il y a je crois 32 communes qui ont
réussi à ouvrir sur 34 et je m'en
réjouis
je m'en réjouis avec tous ceux qui
aiment la france et tous ceux qui aiment
la seine saint denis
parce que voilà quelque chose de social
de la part des maires qu'ils ont fait et
si on se reporte ne serait ce qu'à il y
a une semaine il y a une semaine vous
même
est ce que votre parti disait que les
communes ne rouvrirait pas que le 1er
octobre hall sanitaire était trop
compliqué et bien ce matin le maire m'a
dit que le protocole sanitaire était
tout simplement exigeant mais qu'il
était content de l'avoir respecté et
j'ai vu des enfants heureux avec des
professeurs heureux en train d'accomplir
un objectif social fondamental alors en
matière sociale il ya ceux qui tiennent
des discours vous lie à ce qu'ils
agissent nous
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur philippe gosselin qui part
d'une question de monsieur mansour
kamardine j'ai l'honneur et le plaisir
de représenter et mansour effectivement
mais juste avant puisque je suis la voix
de plusieurs personnes aujourd'hui dire
qu'un de mes collègues me nous on aurait
bien un père les aurais bien aimé parler
des dons de congé pour les soignants
mais je crois que ça va être fait par
d'autres qui ont peut-être un peu piqué
son idée mais bon on y reviendra on y
reviendra
je représente en tout cas aujourd'hui
mon collègue de mayotte matsui kamardine
et je le remercie de sa confiance et de
l'honneur qui me fait et je suis heureux
de représenter ici les ultramarins qui
sont dans une situation un peu délicate
et en particulier je pense aux confiné
de de mayotte depuis quelques semaines
mansour kamardine a alerté différents
ministres sur la situation à mayotte sur
l'insécurité qui y règne
dès le début de la crise et à trois
reprises et il l'a fait et hélas pour le
moment tout cela est resté un peu vain
et les effectifs de gendarmerie de
police n'ont pas vraiment progressé
plus récemment il a aussi un nouveau
interpellé le président de la république
le ministre de l'intérieur la ministre d
outre-mer et aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une situation qui est réellement
catastrophique mais il faudrait
peut-être tenir compte de la réalité de
l'île c'est pas 265 mille habitants mais
en réalité quatre cent mille et il
faudrait ajuster aux vrais effectifs au
vrai nombre de populations et pas aux
chiffres qui sont sous-estimés bref on a
aujourd'hui des vols en bande organisée
on a une attaque aussi d'une caserne de
pompiers avec 50 à 100 personnes qui
s'est déroulé il y à deux jours des
magasins qui sont pillées et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il serait grand temps et
c'est ce que demande mansour kamardine
que des moyens supplémentaires soit
accordée il faut que cela puisse bouger
sur l'île les habitants sont terrorisés
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour venir en aide et se courir
mayotte sur le plan de la sécurité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole et à madame annick girardin
ministre d outre-mer sur le président
mesdames et messieurs
et députés vous avez le député ou non du
député kamardine parler de la situation
de mayotte j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire il ya quelques heures
ouais c'est quelques heures maintenant
dans cet hémicycle effectivement l'état
mais aussi avec une solidarité nationale
mais aussi la réunion fait preuve de
solidité et de soles pardon de
solidarité en faveur de mayotte mais
votre question elle n'est pas sanitaire
parce que c'est une crise sanitaire elle
n'est pas économique parce que c'est
aussi une crise économique mais elle est
sur la violence à mayotte et bien et sur
la sécurité et bien je vais quand même
me dire un certain nombre de choses
parce que les images ont été fortes de
rassemblement de jeunes sur le
territoire de mayotte mais il convient
de distinguer les faits de délinquance
en baisse depuis trois mois
2 - 45 % quand on regarde effectivement
tout ce qui est notamment vol ou
agression à la personne c'est important
de comprendre ce qui s'y passe il ya eu
deux nuits de phénomènes effectivement
qui ont été constatés qu'est ce que
c'est ce sont des jeunes qui sans
désoeuvrés ce sont des faits ponctuels
et vous le savez aussi ce sont des
organisations de combat traditionnel sur
mayotte qui sont qui ont été
effectivement retransmis sur les
différentes chaînes
alors qu'est ce qu'a fait l'état est
bien d'abord on a mobilisé au maximum
les forces sur place et je veux ici les
remercier la police la gendarmerie ils
sont offrant en permanence et vous le
savez et le député kamardine également
et puis le renforcement des forces de
l'ordre également avec l'opération
résilience qui s'est déployé également à
mayotte et qui sont sur le terrain et
qui prennent en charge tout ce qui est
stop alimentaire ou protection des des
commerces
il ya eu aussi et vous le savez le
couvre-feu qui a été installé à mayotte
avec des dispositifs de contrôle de zone
il ya eu un engagement systématique des
forces mobiles on appuie bien sûr à la
police à chaque fois que c'était
nécessaire notamment sur les combats
traditionnels qui ont lieu en ce moment
à mayotte ses opérations sans parfois
nécessité aussi l'engagement de
véhicules blindés de la gendarmerie est
donc tout le monde est sur le terrain
tout le monde est mobilisé pour faire en
sorte effectivement que ces violences
ils sont le plus souvent réalisés par
des jeunes puissent être combattus
important la parole est à monsieur
olivier beige et wim reste quelques
secondes
donc simplement je veux dire au
gouvernement merci monsieur le président
au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités je crois que c'est
important
force doit rester à la loi c'est évident
en france continentale comme dans les
outre-mers à mayotte en particulier
encore faut-il que les forces soient
suffisantes et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
si évident madame la ministre
merci chers collègues la parole et cette
fois monsieur olivier bêche
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre vous avez fait à juste titre
d'ailleurs du port du masque
l'un des piliers de la stratégie de
déconfinement avec bien sûr les gels
hydro alcooliques mais également les
gestes barrières et les tests
il se trouve que aujourd'hui nous avons
encore des difficultés la semaine
dernière particulièrement dans le haut
rhin département qui a été durement
frappé par la crise a trouvé ces masques
c'était un peu la pénurie dans les
supermarchés les bureaux de tabac les
pharmacies on en trouve aujourd'hui
davantage notamment des masques
chirurgicaux mais des masques
chirurgicaux il en faut au minimum trois
par jour puisqu'il faut les échanges et
il ya ce qui représente visiblement une
dépense également pour les pour les
ménages puisque pour un foyer par
exemple de trois personnes ça fait
environ 180 masques par mois soit un
budget de 171 euros
donc nous avons ces difficultés là nous
avons également des difficultés avec des
masques qui sont stockées par les
douanes en dédouanement et qui ne sont
pas qui ne sont pas libérés j'ai cru
comprendre d'ailleurs que ce n'est pas
simplement dans le département du haut
rhin mais également dans d'autres
départements que la question se pose est
donc ma question aujourd'hui est simple
monsieur le ministre
quelle est la stratégie du gouvernement
pour faire en sorte que l'on puisse
avoir davantage de masques
comment faire en sorte que les masses
notamment les masques lavables qui
devaient être distribués par les
collectivités puissent l'être
c'est-à-dire accélérer les procédures de
certification beaucoup sont encore
bloqués aujourd'hui par des questions de
bureaucratie et enfin monsieur le
ministre
quelle stratégie
à moyen terme c'est à dire dans les
prochaines semaines pour garantir à
l'approvisionnement en masque de manière
durable
merci beaucoup merci chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur olivier veyrat
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
monsieur le député olivier becht nous
interroger sur m'interroger sur l'accès
aux masques j'imagine masque grand
public n'avait pas parlé de masques de
soignants d'abord vous dire que ça a été
une aventure de toute la nation qui a
été entamée il ya plusieurs semaines
plus près ce que plusieurs mois
désormais pour d'abord élaborer des
normes des normes afnor permettant à la
france de se doter de masques destinés
au grand public qui sont filtrant
minimum 70% filtration pour les
particules de 1 à 3 microns c'est-à-dire
empêchant les gouttelettes virale de
traverser et allant dans la plupart des
cas d'ailleurs à 90% de filtration
c'est-à-dire presqu'au niveau de
filtration des masques destinés aux
soignants avec ses marques grand public
qui ont la particularité d'être lavables
cinq dix vingt trente fois ces masques
nous avons quand je dis que c'est une
aventure de la nation c'est que nous
avons appelé l'ensemble des entreprises
l'ensemble des industries qui peuvent
produire des masques à se lancer dans
cette production de masques de manière à
alimenter l'ensemble du marché français
l'état prend toute sa part avec 20
millions de masques distribués chaque
semaine auprès de ses propres opérateurs
de ses agents les enseignants nous
l'avons vu les collégiens mais également
5 millions de masques qui sont donnés
aux collectivités pour être distribuée
via les ccs chaque semaine aux personnes
les plus précaires vous avez également
le réseau des pharmacies qui participent
activement cette distribution de masques
grand public la grande distribution il
en a été beaucoup question les
transports publics qui on a eu
l'occasion de distribuer un certain
nombre de masques dès hier matin pour
permettre aux voyageurs qu'ils n'en
avaient pas d'aller travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
poser la question du test des masques je
pourrais vous en parler très longtemps
vita se démasque juste vous dire qu'il y
à une étape qui est importante
lorsque les masques vienne rentrer sur
le territoire national oui il faut un
peu de vérification oui il faut que ça
aille vite
mais les masques sont innombrables
aujourd'hui entre les masques soignants
et des masques grand public il ne faut
pas laisser rentrer sur le territoire
des masques qui serait
de mauvaise qualité sans quoi on serait
amené à les détruire ou à les stocker là
où il faut il faut qu'on soit sûr qu'on
protège les français avec du bon
matériel nous faisons tout en oeuvre
systématiquement pour accompagner les
collectivités les entreprises pour
accélérer les procédures au niveau de la
douane et j'en profite pour terminer
pour saluer l'action des députés qui a
permis de prendre un arrêté qui passe la
tva sur ces masques à 5 5%
y compris pour les masques des
couturières lorsqu ils correspondent aux
normes c'est une très bonne décision du
parlement et je remercie ce prêt la
parole est à monsieur eric coquerel vous
avez la parole
merci hier on encore compter 263 décès
dus aux copies 19d épistémologue disent
craindre une deuxième vague en juillet
je ne vous apprends rien nous savons
tous que la partie n'est pas gagnée
hier on a aussi beaucoup parlé des
personnes profitant des berges du canal
saint martin à paris
on a entendu de nouveau les rengaines
sur le relâchement des français si
quelques cas individuels ont oublié les
gestes barrière je ne voudrais pas que
ce soit l'arbre qui cache la forêt et
les responsabilités car la réussite du
déconfinement va surtout se jouer dans
les lieux collectifs confiné et en
priorité dans les transports en commun
or hier les images les plus choquantes
était celle de la ligne 13 du métro ou b
du rer
venant du nord parisien certes les gens
entassés avec quasi tous des masques les
travailleurs ne sont pas suicidaires
mais chacun sait que le masque dans ces
conditions extrêmes n'assure pas une
protection à 100 % d'autant que vu leur
prix nul ne sait si tous sont des normes
afnor où sont changés aussi fréquemment
qu'il se doit c'est d'ailleurs cette
raison sanitaire qui nous a vu exiger
aussi leurs discussions gratuite à
l'entrée les transports on nous dit que
des problèmes techniques expliquent
cette influence sur ces deux lignes que
le trafic global était bien assuré à 75%
ce n'est pas une excuse d'une part
chacun sait que les problèmes techniques
sont fréquents sur ses lignes et que le
nombre de trains mise en service doit
les anticiper chacune des voitures
bondées pouvant devenir un cluster
d'autre part 75% est une moyenne et
informations prises auprès des syndicats
on était plus proche de 60% sur ses
lignes et tronçons les plus fréquentés
d'où une première question qu'allez vous
mettre en oeuvre concrètement ce pour
assurer à assurer la sécurité sanitaire
optimum des travailleurs contraints de
prendre les transports en commun sachant
qu'en plus
leur nom va grossir dans les jours à
venir je m'adresse aux gouvernements car
c'est vous le donneur d'ordre celui qui
a choisi la date de déconfinement c'est
donc vous qui n'avez pas le droit à
l'erreur et bien évidemment cette
question ne remet pas en question les
agents et cheminots que vous avez
souhaité il ya peu privés de leur régime
de retraite tellement il était
privilégiée merci monsieur débuté la
boll est à monsieur jean baptiste
djebbari secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous permettez de
rappeler ici la stratégie que nous avons
concerté construit avec les élus
notamment les élus de l'île de france et
qui s'exécute depuis hier dans des
conditions globalement satisfaisante
vous rappelle les trois axes de la
stratégie d'abord d'avoir le maximum
d'offres possible vous avez cité le
chiffre de 75 % et les correct il a été
réalisé et c'est un peu plus sur
certaines lignes 85% sur la ligne 13 100
% sur les lignes automatiques ensuite
nous avons conçu une stratégie qui
permet d'avoir le moins de monde
possible au moment critique les heures
de pointe
ça passe par l'organisation du
télétravail ça a bien marché
hier et nous organisons comme vous le
savez un système d'attestation qui
permettra de réguler le nombre de
voyageurs aux heures de pointe et
ensuite monsieur le député nous avons
pris des mesures fortes sur le plan
sanitaire
vous l'avez dit vous-même nous avons
imposé le port du masque est plus de 95%
et hier 98 % aujourd'hui
des voyageurs avaient un masque ou s'en
sont vu doter un notamment avec l'effort
de l'état des deux millions de masques
que nous avons distribué partout en
france depuis hier nous avons
effectivement monsieur le député connu
quelques difficultés notamment le matin
du fait des intempéries difficultés que
nous avons corrigé
d'abord en réorganisant les missions les
équipes d'inspection filtrage dans plus
de 400 points en france et puis en
mettant un peu plus d'offres nous allons
continuer à le faire les jours qui
viennent de manière à toujours permettre
aux voyageurs de se déplacer en sécurité
sanitaire vous voyez monsieur le député
nous faisons comme vous j'imagine la
sécurité des voyageurs une priorité
politique
merci monsieur le ministre nous
poursuivons notre séance avec des
questions portant sur des thèmes
économiques et sociaux
monsieur christophe bouillon vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre leur est alors
reprise progressive dans les écoles elle
se fait au compte gouttes
elle se fait dans des conditions
particulières elle se fait sur le regard
inquiet des parents on a beaucoup parlé
du rôle du maire il a été déterminant
mais il ne faut pas oublier les
enseignants qui ont assuré un
enseignement à distance qui a révélé ses
limites
ils ont été formidables nous voulons le
rendre un hommage appuyé l'heure n'est
pas à la reprise pour les apprentis
puisque vous avez annoncé l'obtention
des diplômes crp et bep en contrôle
continu ceux ci qui se comprend
parfaitement
nous avons la conviction que
l'apprentissage est une filière
d'excellence notre pays a la chance de
compter plus de 500000 apprentis mais
les enseignements théoriques et
pratiques et gage de réussite les
artisans et les entreprises
reconnaissent les vertus la crise
sanitaire n'a pas épargné
l'apprentissage les centres de formation
ont dû fermer et des apprentis sous
contrat ont été mis au chômage partiel
des précieuses semaines ont été perdus
il faut permettre au cfa et aux
entreprises concernées de pouvoir
rattraper les heures de formation
manquantes
nous souhaitons l'allongement jusqu'à un
an du délai permettant inscrits du reste
est en apprentissage pour trouver un
employeur
nous souhaitons qu'un volet
apprentissage figure en bonne place dans
le plan de relance il faut donner de la
visibilité la perspective aux secteurs
les plus touchés comme le btp
l'hôtellerie restauration pour permettre
le maintien des contrats d'apprentissage
si ces secteurs plonge ce sont des
gisements importants de l'apprentissage
qui disparaissent les apprentis risquent
d'être les premiers sacrifiés des plans
d'économies dans des entreprises
il faut maintenir les sources de
financement des cfa et 5 millions
d'euros des d'annoncé ne suffiront pas
pourquoi ne pas imaginer des avantages
fiscaux partenariat avec les régions
pour favoriser le regroupement le
recrutement pardon d'apprentis pourquoi
ne pas encourager le développement
massif de contrats d'alternance ou
d'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique pour pallier une éventuelle
baisse de l'offre dans le secteur privé
nous savons tous que l'apprentissage a
connu des hauts et des bas nous savons
tous qu'il a pourtant fait ses preuves
il faut aider l'apprentissage quoi qu'il
en coûte madame la ministre que comptez
vous faire pour la relance de
l'apprentissage
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
christophe bouillon le remercie de
souligner l'apprentissage crois qu'on
est tous convaincus que c'est une voie
d'excellence d'avenir c'était le sens de
la loi pour la liberté de choisir son
avenir professionnel et grâce à la loi
et grâce à la mobilisation de absolument
tous les acteurs nous avons
effectivement presque atteint les 500
milles apprentis et je crois commencé à
changer l'image l'apprentissage dans
notre pays pour comprendre que c'est un
des métiers d'avenir de passion et
d'excellence alors dans la crise
économique qui suit la crise épidémique
nous avons pris immédiatement de
nombreuses mesures pour déjà
sauvegardées les contrats actuels
nous avons permis que les contrats
d'apprentissage puisse être prolongé de
six mois jusqu'au aux examens nous avons
maintenu le coc contrat dans les cfa
pour qu'il n'ait aucun problème
financier même si les apprentis n'était
pas là nous avons permis la formation à
distance et 90% des cff ont pu faire la
formation à distance des apprentis nous
avons permis aussi que lorsque
l'entreprise est fermée où son activité
fermer les jeunes en apprentissage
puisse être au chômage partiel à 100% de
leur rémunération
je vous fais pas la liste complète mais
on a vraiment sauvegarde et
l'apprentissage le résultat c'est qu'on
a très peu de ruptures de contrat pas
plus que les autres années
je crois que c'est déjà un succès et
deuxièmement que neuf apprentis sur dix
a pu suivre sa formation à distance mais
maintenant vous même porte tabler sur la
suite alors je vous le dis très
clairement et je me réjouis qu'on soit
ensemble sur ce sujet qu'on soit tous
ensemble j'espère surtout les bancs
l'apprentissage fera partie des
priorités du programme de relance que
nous allons proposer
pourquoi parce que c'est une voie
d'avenir comme je les dis et puis de
même que l'investissement dans la
jeunesse dans l'éducation nationale sera
importante
c'est pour ça que nous préparons aussi
ce plan avec le miz l'éducation
nationale le ministre de l'agriculture
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
nous pensons qu'il faut absolument monte
donner un signal à la jeunesse que
investir dans l'avenir c'est investir
dans la jeunesse donc dans
l'apprentissage
nous consulterons actuellement les
partenaires sociaux tous les acteurs de
la profession donc il est trop tôt pour
dire les modalités mais nous serons tous
ensemble je pense pour développer
l'apprentissage pour relancer
l'apprentissage et des ordis déjà les
cfa ouvre pour la plupart la semaine
prochaine merci
la parole est à madame marie george
buffet parole madame la ministre des
sports le mouvement sportif subit
également les conséquences de la
pandémie
pourtant durant le confinement la
pratique sportive est apparu comme un
besoin essentiel de l'individu qu'il
soit amateur ou professionnel si
l'ensemble du sport français qui
affronte cette crise bien sûr les
enseignements seront attirés le sport
professionnel a besoin pour sa survie
même de plus de diversité de régulation
dans ses ressources financières
mais c'est la situation des fédérations
et des clubs le terreau de la pratique
sportive qui fonde ma question
en effet des fédérations et nombre de
clubs voient leur trésorerie mise à mal
n'ayant pu organiser les événements qui
assurent leur financement les
initiatives municipales permettant au
club d'accueillir les parents les
licenciés pour recueillir leurs
adhésions sont supprimés l'accès aux
aides de l'état visant les petites
entreprises
laure et quasiment fermée comment les
clubs amateurs vont-ils boucler leur
budget et comment vont-ils conforter et
conquérir des pratiquants et du
pratiquante
l'avenir du mouvement sportif le
développement des pratiques se joue
maintenant nous devons préparer la
rentrée de septembre en deux temps un
premier temps qui est celui de l'urgence
en s'assurant qu'aucun club ne ferme à
cause de la crise un fonds d'urgence ne
doit-il pas être mise en place pour cela
à l'instar de ce qui a été fait dans
d'autres domaines
puis dans un second temps un plan de
relance de la pratique sportive pour la
rentrée de septembre est à bâtir des
responsables fédéraux craignent un
nombre de licenciés en baisse du fait de
la période de crise sanitaire que nous
traversons lever les freins à l'envi de
reprendre le sport cela peut être un
beau défi aussi madame la ministre
quel plan de relance de la pratique
sportive envisagez-vous au niveau du
ministère et quelle sera selon vous
l'action de l' agence nationale du sport
pour permettre au mouvement sportif
d'être dans la proximité des clubs a pas
répondre au bout des fidji hop et 2024
je vous remercie
merci maracineanu ministre des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la ministre cher mari georges
je viens d'une association comme
sportive comme dirigeante bénévole et
j'ai aussi été salariée associative
je sais combien nos clubs crée le lien
social et contribue à faire société et
faire société aujourd'hui nous en avons
besoin plus que jamais je partage donc
votre attachement à notre formidable
tissu associatif sportif leurs actions
de solidarité de ces dernières semaines
illustrent le rôle que les associations
ont déjà et la place qu'elles peuvent
occuper demain en matière sociale
d'éducation de santé d'inclusion de
citoyenneté je me suis battu pour
qu'elle soit protégée pendant cette
crise notre gouvernement leur a ouvert
tous les dispositifs de soutien fonds de
solidarité chômage partiel l'exonération
des charges comme pour n'importe quelle
entreprise en france de son côté l'
agence nationale du sport a maintenu et
adapter ses dispositifs de soutien à
l'emploi et au projet sportif fédéraux
qui irrigue désormais le tissu
associatif local
aux côtés des collectivités des
collectivités avec qui nous sommes en
contact permanent grâce à l' agence pour
qu'elle maintienne elles aussi leurs
subventions aux sports aujourd'hui les
associations vont continuer à être
soutenus car elles ne reprendront pas à
plein régime tout de suite la pratique
sportive est entré dans le quotidien des
citoyens confiné vous l'avez dit elle va
devoir affronter le challenge d'une
reprise en groupe dans un club dans une
équipe
le sport qui se regardent à la télé
celui qui se vend celui qui grâce à vous
madame buffet rapport de l'argent au
sport qui se pratique au sport pour tous
est aujourd'hui en grande difficulté il
faut l'aider lui aussi à se relever nous
préparons déjà un plan de relance du
sport en cohérence avec les projets des
territoires l'enjeu sera de remettre les
français en mouvement pour bouger et
s'engager garder captifs les fonds
privés investis dans le sport
sanctuariser les subventions publiques
dédiées au sport et travail et à ouvrir
des portes nouvelle à nos associations
leur ouvrir celle de l'école est un
premier pas important
au delà de la reprise de l'activité de
nos clubs nous devons imaginer le sport
de demain une activité au service de la
santé de l'éducation du bien-être et du
vivre ensemble
merci
la parole est à monsieur dominique
potier merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre vous connaissez tous je pense
le tableau de goya qui s'appelle la rixe
de lutter armés de bâtons des sables
mouvants
à chaque coup il s'enfonce à la pandémie
a comme unis dans nos consciences et
horizons de la fin du mois et de la fin
du monde et nous avons la responsabilité
de tracer une trajectoire une
trajectoire périlleuse zéro chômage zéro
carbone une trajectoire périlleuse et
dans cet instant le risque est grand
pour chacun de jouer 2022 au plus
habiles alors même qu'une montée de la
pauvreté de l'insécurité sociale
signifierait pour reprendre les mots du
premier ministre
un écroulement démocratique possible en
2022 aux élections présidentielles je
veux plus habile c'est parfois reprendre
les mots des autres pour les désactiver
nous avons jamais connu aussi
révolutionnaire sur le nouveau monde sur
la fin sur le nouveau capitalisme etc
vous avez des mots nouveaux repris
souvent à gauche mais qui peine à se
traduire en actes et qui plus tôt nous
laisse dubitatif au vu du refus des
réformes structurelles et des processus
de changement que nous avions suggéré
les mois et les années précédentes
vous empruntez à gauche vous empruntez
parfois à droite quand il s'agit des
finances ou du budget ou le ministre
darmanin dit avec clarté qu'il refuse
toute réforme fiscale en vue d'éponger
dans la décennie qui vient
la dette contractée pour la france pour
sauver son économie et sa société et
cela nous laisse vraiment mari au moment
où nous aurions dû au contraire
envisager l'abolition des privilèges
fiscaux
nous avons fait au moins cinq
propositions sont au rang sur ceux des
socialistes et propositions qui vont de
la lutte contre l' optimisation fiscale
sur le modèle de gabriel zucman à lutte
contre les écarts de revenus indécents
la réparation des erreurs du début de
mandat
toutes ces propositions visent à sauver
l'économie réelle à rétablir la justice
dans notre pays
dans l'esprit de roosevelt maintenir les
balance de la justice égale pour tous
nous avons moins besoin de machiavel que
de roosevelt êtes vous prêt à un
dialogue en vérité sociale écologique et
économique pour engager cette
trajectoire dans la justice
bien dit machiavel ni rosebel de la
parole est à madame agnès tenir une ag
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
potier merci d'abord pour toutes ces
références intellectuelles des grands
hommes qui ont apporté leur pierre
roosevelt nous avez ouvert le chemin en
prévoyant des plans de relance très
important à la suite de la crise de 1929
et je crois que cette inspiration peut
nous guider et et je veux redire ici
tout ce que le gouvernement a fait ces
quelques dernières semaines justement
non pour prononcer des paroles fortes ou
écrire des tribunes encore plus forte
mais pour être dans l'action et le
sauvetage non seulement des entreprises
mais des millions d'emplois qui sont
derrière ces entreprises et faire que
cette crise sanitaire ne soit pas une
crise sociale majeure
de quoi parle-t-on on parle d'un plan de
110 milliards d'euros 110 milliards
d'euros qui sont uniquement dédié à
sauver le lien entre le salarié et son
entreprise c'est le chômage partiel
l'activité partielle que muriel pénicaud
amis très rapidement en place et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui près d'un salarié
sur deux doit son salaire à l'état un
salarié du privé sur deux sauvées
également la trésorerie des entreprises
et ça c'est du concret la trésorerie des
moyennes et grandes entreprises ils
voulaient voter merci pour cela parce
que ça aussi c'est du concret sauver
enfin les indépendants avec le fonds de
solidarité
ce fonds de solidarité qui aujourd'hui
permet à des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises de survivre et de tran
situation de passer le cap
après ce plan de sauvetage via des plans
de soutien
nous travaillons sur l'automobile je
sais que vous êtes attachés à cette
industrie particulièrement nous
travaillons sur l'aéronautique car
kebela devenir de l'industrie
aéronautique au moment où l'aviation
commerciale est dans une situation de
quasi arrêt des plans pour le tourisme
là aussi c'est du concret
c'est des emplois sur l'ensemble des
territoires donc nous allons au delà des
paroles nous posons des actes et des
actes de solidarité
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur paul christophe merci monsieur
le président j'ai intervient au nom de
mes collègues philippe dunoyer philippe
gomès maina sage et nichols anker qui
souhaitent interroger madame la ministre
d outre-mer madame la ministre le
transport aérien figure au premier rang
des secteurs économiques les plus
lourdement impacté par la pandémie de
kobe de 19
le gouvernement a parfaitement identifié
cette menace en se portant dans un
premier temps au chevet d'air france qui
bénéficiera en plus des mesures de
chômage partiel d'un plan de soutien de
sept milliards d'euros soit l'équivalent
de 45% de son chiffre d'affaires annuel
des aides spécifiques devraient
également bénéficier à air austral ou à
corsair nous tenons aujourd'hui à vous
alerter sur la situation critique de
certaines compagnies aériennes
régionales des collectivités françaises
du pacifique ces compagnies assurent
quasiment seule la desserte et le
désenclavement de nos territoires
à titre d'exemple aircalin et air tahiti
nui représentent respectivement 80 % et
60 % du trafic international vers la
nouvelle calédonie et la polynésie
française
cette compagnie permettent d'alimenter
l'industrie touristique et hôtelière
important ressorts économiques que nos
archipels notamment en polynésie où le
tourisme pèse 15 % du pib' nos
compagnies ultramarines sur le lien avec
l'hexagone au titre de la continuité
territoriale et font travailler
plusieurs milliers de salariés dont
l'emploi est désormais menacé la
faillite de ces compagnies constituerait
un désastre économique et social leur
survie revêt donc une importance
stratégique pour la france et ses
collectivités
ces compagnies ont déjà sollicité le
prêt garanti par l'état mais c'était ne
dépassera pas 25% de leur dernier
chiffre d'affaires annuel
face à une perte d'activité de plus de
80% en 2020 chacun comprendra que ne
s'en sortiront pas sans un soutien
infini ficp et civiques
madame la ministre la question est la
suivante tout comme air france
considérez vous que ces entreprises ont
intérêt stratégique et par conséquent
quelle mesure envisagez-vous pour éviter
leur disparition
merci
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame annick girardin ministre d
outre-mer c'est le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
christophe vous avez effectivement
évoqué la situation des compagnies
aériennes des territoires d'outre-mer il
est évident que cette crise sanitaire l
adc tue aussi une crise économique
nous venons d'en parler et elle a touché
fortement effectivement le monde de
l'aérien c'est plus de 60 % de
diminution en france ou de baisse en
france du trafic aérien qu'on va
connaître cette année on voit bien
l'importance de ce secteur qui est
soutenu par les tailles pour qui
continuera à l'être alors comment oui il
ya une perte de chiffre d'affaires bien
sûr dans l'ensemble de ses compagnies et
les territoires d'outre-mer et bien
c'est air austral et air tahiti nui et
air câlin vous avez cité saint pierre
c'est air caraïbes selon les bassins
maritimes nous avons des compagnies dans
les territoires ultramarins qui est vous
l'avez aussi dit et je veux leur
rappeler aussi ont un rôle essentiel de
continuité territoriale et je veux
remercier celle qui avec l'état en
continu est effectivement dans ce moment
difficile à assumer des vols avec très
peu de passagers à bord et des vols de
fret et ce n'est pas tout le monde
et en ce qui concerne effectivement le
pacifique pour la calédonie
effectivement aircalin a continué pour
air tahiti nui c'est l'état aujourd'hui
qui assume le pont aérien avec la
polynésie mais que faire et comment les
soutenir demain de manière à
effectivement faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse continuer ce travail essentiel de
continuité territoriale alors vous
l'avais dit il ya bien sûr cet
accompagnement notamment dans les
territoires du pacifique des prêts de
trésorerie garantis par l'état qui était
mis en place et elles ont utilisé ce
dispositif
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que ça
représentait effectivement 25%
c'est aujourd'hui trois mois de chiffre
d'affaires que nous pouvons
effectivement couvrir par ce prêt
garanti par la bpi mais faut aller plus
loin et bruno le maire l'a dit au delà à
d'air france nous accompagnerons bien
sûr les autres compagnies aériennes mais
là il faut aussi être clair c'est une
collective c'est une responsabilité
collective et nous devons aussi
travailler avec l'ensemble des
actionnaires qui souvent d'ailleurs sont
des collectivités territoriales ou c'est
plutôt le pays en calédonie et en
polynésie également et on doit
travailler
les collectifs ensemble et il y aura un
groupe de travail qui se mettre en place
très immersive l'histoire la parole est
à monsieur christophe blanchet merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
du travail
nous sommes tous reconnaissants
admiratif du dévouement et du courage
dont font preuve ces femmes et ces
hommes du monde soignants auprès des
malades de leurs familles et de nos
aînés notre système de santé tient car
le soignant tiennent bon ils se sont
adaptés avec une réactivité et une
agilité dans des conditions difficiles
faisant honneur à leur vocation demain
le grand plan santé que prépare le
gouvernement devrait être une réponse
forte car vital est attendu aujourd'hui
nous devons aussi entendre les
applaudissements solidaire que les
français adresse depuis leurs fenêtres
cette reconnaissance qu'ils expriment
est aussi la volonté pour un grand
nombre de vouloir agir directement pour
aider davantage notre devoir est
d'interpréter cette demande de
fraternité et de lui donner forme à cet
effet madame la ministre nous en avons
adressé il ya trois semaines avec 100
députés de la majorité une proposition
offrir la possibilité pour les salariés
qui le veulent dans le public comme dans
le privé de faire don d'une partie de
leurs congés payés ou rtt au bénéfice de
ceux qui luttent directement contre le
coc vide 19
ce dispositif n'est pas une charge
supplémentaire pour l'état ni pour les
entreprises car ces congés sont déjà
provisionné ainsi récupérées sur rack
uniquement de volontariat il constitue
une somme qui sera redistribué sous
forme de chèques vacances nous
permettrions au personnel soignant
lorsqu'ils prendront quelques jours de
congé bien mérité de profiter de bons
moments supplémentaires partager en
famille dans un restaurant un hôtel
amusé un parc de loisirs ou autre à
titre indicatif
si chacun des 23 millions de salariés en
france donne juste un de ces jours alors
ce serait deux milliards d'euros
consommer dans notre économie
touristique locale et nationale
madame la ministre qu'elle suit le
gouvernement entend donner à cette
proposition solidaire au tant sociale
qu'économique porté par les députés de
la majorité
merci chers collègues la parole talent
et s'il vous plaît la parole et à madame
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail même
si je suis content de retrouver un
certain nombre de collègues en pleine
santé vous avez la parole dans l'âme la
mise
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député christophe blanche
est d'abord merci de faire une
proposition collective importante sur
les solidarités
dans un contexte où le président de la
république a appelé a aussi inventé
multiplier les formes de solidarité j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire devant la
mission d'information de la conférence
des présidents de cette assemblée je
considère cette proposition comme très
intéressante
pourquoi parce que au-delà de leurs
applaudissements beaucoup de salariés de
citoyens en france souhaite trouver des
formes pour manifester leur soutien aux
soignants qui sont depuis deux mois au
front au fond du coc u19 et qu'ils
souhaitent
en plus de tout ce que fait le
gouvernement mais encouragés et donc sur
ce sujet là je pense que la proposition
de permettre à des salariés du secteur
public comme du secteur privé à titre
évidemment volontaire de pouvoir donner
de pouvoir faire un don de jour de repos
est une initiative intéressante
évidemment on ne sait pas quelle est
l'ampleur de ce que ça pourra
représenter ça dépendra du volontariat
mais c'est intéressant aussi le couple
est avec les chèques vacances comme vous
le proposez puisque c'est aussi le
tourisme un secteur qui est en
difficulté et c'est une manière jeu de
jouer collectif à la fois pour la santé
mais aussi pour le secteur du tourisme
donc au tour du gouvernement je peux
vous confirmer que je soutiens
pleinement votre proposition que nous
allons travailler ensemble sur les
modalités de son exécution
il faut définir les modalités de
conversion des jours de repos
une somme d'argent il faut gérer le
dispositif sur les modalités de
répartition entre les bénéficiaires
enfin ça soulève toute une série de
questions mais quand on a la volonté
on y arrive et je pense qu'on est dans
une crise exceptionnelle et toutes les
innovations doivent être encouragées
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur pierre dharréville madame la
ministre
l'activité est en train de se relancer
tant bien que mal et l'on a le sentiment
que nous allons plus subir la relance
que la piloter or ce ralentissement est
venu nous interroger sur cette course
folle dans laquelle nous sommes engagés
gaspillant à tout va le travail et la
matière habillement les humains et la
planète
il a vu l'émergence de nombreuses
interrogations sur les ressorts de notre
machine économique sur l'incurie du
capitalisme on a parlé de relocaliser
les productions de reprendre la main sur
le marché d'échapper au couple infernal
consumérisme productivisme de respecter
la santé au travail et de revaloriser
les métiers nous devons affronter dans
un même mouvement une crise qui portait
déjà auparavant et la nécessité
d'accélérer la transition écologique
mais la guerre économique n'a jamais
cessé et les amis du medef sont déjà sur
le pont pour faire payer la crise et ses
enjeux aux salariés et s'ils ne faisons
rien nous ne pourrons relever aucun des
deux défis social et environnemental
alors le monde d'après ressemblera
furieusement à celui d'avant empire nous
devons conserver nos sites de production
et amplifier leur transformation
il y a besoin d'investissements massifs
dans les transports et l'industrie et
pas après demain parlez-nous par exemple
de la sidérurgie
vous avez annoncé globalement un plan
pour l'automne pour certains sites
certains secteurs il sera déjà trop tard
l'intervention publique doit être
l'occasion de permettre aux salariés et
dans les secteurs stratégiques à l'état
à la puissance publique de gagner des
leviers dans la gestion ou en êtes-vous
du point de vue de l'utilisation
jusqu'ici brumeuse des 20 milliards de
provisions hâtive ont un véritable fonds
stratégique pour une relance
industrielle écologique et sociale
sécurisant les emplois rien ne se
règlera dans deux petites tractations en
catimini il ya besoin d'un vrai
mouvement démocratique jusque dans les
entreprises et l'économie
allez vous pensez la relance avec
l'ensemble des acteurs à ciel ouvert
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
madame agnès pannier rina chez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
nous vivons un moment assez inédit
puisque je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce que vous peser monsieur
dharréville effectivement la relancer la
reconstruction industrielle ne se fera
pas en faisant l'économie de la
transition écologique énergétique et
j'ajouterais si vous le permettez
également de la transition numérique
parce que nous avons pendant deux mois
vécus
grâce à nos infrastructures numériques
et nous voyons tout le bénéfice qu'on
peut en tirer
y compris d'ailleurs en matière de
transition économique et écologique et
d'économie d'émissions de co2 donc oui
c'est la direction dans laquelle nous
allons et avec bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie notre plan il se
fait en trois phases un plan d'urgence
celui que vous avez voté à deux reprises
en le complétant et qui vise à tenir la
tête hors de l'eau des entreprises et
faire en sorte que les salariés ne
perdent pas leur emploi ils soient
continue à être rémunérée un plan de
soutien qui va être destiné à un certain
nombre de secteurs nous avons annoncé le
tourisme une vision large du tourisme
hôtellerie quoi pardon restauration café
est également l'aéronautique et
l'automobile
mais au-delà de ces plans un plan de
relance qui se positionnera plus tôt en
septembre c'est à dire au moment où on
verra là l'équilibré de la croissance et
de la consommation
le plan de soutien ce sont ces mesures
immédiates qui peuvent concerner la
sidérurgie car lorsqu'on parle
automobile on parle sidérurgie c'est la
mode de l'automobile et nous sommes en
train d'y travailler non seulement au
niveau national mais également au niveau
européen puisque j'avais ma collègue
espagnol le téléphone qui voulaient
spécifiquement porté un plan sur ce
sujet là sur l'automobile et sur la
sidérurgie
donc oui nous avons un plan organiser la
reconquête industrielle qui était au
coeur de notre politique économique est
plus que jamais confirmé on voit
l'intérêt de créer créer des emplois en
france des emplois productifs des
emplois qui tirent l'ensemble de la
machine économique
merci madame la ministre la parole et à
monsieur olivier marc l'ex ministre le
gouvernement français a décidé de venir
au secours des france comme tous les
étals enfin l'égard de leurs compagnies
nationales et c'est incontestablement
une bonne décision pour la compagnie et
pour l'emploi vous avez cependant
conditionné votre plan de sauvetage à
l'accélération du plan de transformation
et de compétitivité de la compagnie qui
comportera un volet ressources humaines
avec des suppressions d'effectifs dans
les fonctions support de l'entreprise
ainsi que l'a d'ores et déjà annoncé ben
smith il est regrettable que ce port de
restructuration dont votre gouvernement
a fait la condition pour venir en aide
ne soit pas rendue publique en même
temps que votre décision de soutien
c'est donc ma première demande le rendre
public
et la seconde de manière un peu plus
précise quelles garanties
avez vous demandé au président d'air
france pour protéger les emplois
français pour protéger la place de nos
compatriotes
à l'occasion de cette restructuration
l'idée assez simple que je défende et
tant que l'argent apporté par l'état
français doit servir en priorité surtout
si des restructurations à préserver
l'emploi français y compris dans les
fonctions d'encadrement et de management
merci madame agnès berger secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre l'économie et
des finances
l'appareil merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député à part dont c'est toi
non monsieur le député merlex
je vais pour doc sous le contrôle de
bada mme borne qui est ministre des
transports qui a joué un rôle éminent
dans la cette restructuration d'air
france qu'avons nous fait d'abord avec
air france les ai parlé la ministre ne
vous laissez pas troublé qu'avons nous
fait venant au secours d'air france nous
avons posé un certain nombre de
fondamentaux le premier fondamental
c'est est d'engager air france dans la
transition écologique énergétique un pas
plus loin avec dans le contrat qui nous
lie et nouer avec la compagnie des
engagements très précis que ce soit en
termes d'innovation mais que ce soit
aussi en termes d'investissements dans
les biocarburants dans le fait de se
tourner vers une aviation de nouvelle
génération et que nous accompagnons au
niveau de la filière aéronautique aussi
en leur demandant de faire cet effort
donc ceci est un effort cohérent
deuxième élément effectivement nous
investissons pas à fonds perdus mais
nous essayons de penser l'avenir d'avoir
une compagnie aérienne française qui
soit capable de redémarrer avec la
croissance et le redémarrage de
l'aviation commerciale et je crois que
les discussions que nous avons avec air
france elle doit se nouer aussi si vous
le permettez c'est la démocratie sociale
avec les salariés d'air france avec les
organisations syndicales d'air france
c'est la façon dont ça se déroule
habituellement c'est une discussion qui
doit permettre de définir les conditions
de sauvetage de cette compagnie pour que
nous ayons demain une compagnie qui
conserve sa place dans le jeu mondial
des compagnies aériennes et qui soit
capable aussi de garantir à notre
empreinte de deux les compagnies une
présence française importante et vous le
savez l'essentiel de cet argent il est
pour les emplois français
merci
[Applaudissements]
l'ex ministre et la ministre des
transports a peut-être l'occasion de
compléter la réponse à ma question à la
ministre s'était la préservation de
l'emploi de nos compatriotes français
dans l'entreprise et notamment dans les
instances dirigeantes de l'entreprise
dans l'encadrement partout à vrai dire
dans cette entreprise qui requit qui
emploie plus de quarante mille personnes
sur à peu près aujourd'hui tous les tous
les continents je n'ai pas eu de réponse
à cette question mais au moment où la
compagnie demande l'aide de l'état je
pense qu'il serait bienvenu que l'état
lui demande de faire une place
particulière pour cette préoccupation de
la place des français dans le management
de l'entreprise la nationalité des
candidats n'est pas quelque chose
d'anecdotique madame la ministre
merci chers collègues de ce complément
la parole à madame céline calvaise merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
culture à cause de la crise certains
diront que la culture s'est arrêtée tout
net
non la culture n'a pas disparu mais nous
vivons la culture d'une autre manière
le confinement j'en suis certaine a
marqué la place cruciale de la culture
dans notre société auprès de chacune et
chacun de nos concitoyens nous avons
tous apprécié la maîtrise l'ingéniosité
la ténacité des artistes créateurs
inspirés par le confinement capable
d'entamer ensemble les plus beaux
morceaux bien que distants de milliers
de kilomètres ces artistes qui se sont
exprimés ne nous ont pas fait oublier
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
contribuent à tous les niveaux à la
vitalité culturelle de notre pays et
dont nous sommes fiers très fier
pourtant certains ont cru qu'ils étaient
invisibles
je souhaite le dire dans cet hémicycle
non les acteurs de la culture peuvent
compter sur nous comme nous espérons
pouvoir compter de demain encore plus
qu'hier sur leur créativité et leur
talent pour réinventer notre manière de
vivre
c'est la promesse d'une belle aventure
pour mylène qu'une des rats laventure
c'était comme une façon d'embrasser le
monde
à l'heure où le monde ne peut plus
vraiment s'embrasser il sera déterminant
de donner à la culture cette mission
celle d'embrasser le monde pour
accompagner les acteurs culturels le
président de la république et vous même
vous avez posé des actes forts un plan
de soutien important a été mis en place
cette sectorielle d'urgence dès le 19
mars un plan renforcé le 6 mai notamment
grâce à une année blanche pour les
intermittents qui tel un filet de
sécurité va leur permettre de continuer
à créer monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous rassure et au delà de la cette
prolongation des droits sur la question
de la date anniversaire le soutien et
public le soutient et massif il doit
également impliquer les acteurs privés
notamment ceux qui ont encore plus
émergé à la faveur de la fermeture des
lieux culturels
ainsi il est juste que les plateformes
numériques participent à l'effort de
soutien de notre création française et
européenne et c'est l'essence même de la
directive et sema que le président a
promis pour être transposée avant le 1er
janvier 2021 au fond monsieur le
ministre comment dans les prochains mois
invitée chaque acteur culturel ainsi que
chacune et chacun d'entre nous c'est le
monde grâce à la culture merci chers
collègues la parole est à monsieur
franck riester ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la député
calvet le secteur de la culture et
particulièrement touchées par ces crises
le gouvernement dès le départ a souhaité
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mesures fortes d'urgence que j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion dans cette assemblée de
présenter tant des mesures transversales
pour tous les secteurs économiques
auxquels les acteurs de la culture ont
accès mais aussi des mesures spécifiques
mises en place par le ministère de la
culture
le président la république la semaine
dernière a réaffirmé son soutien fort au
secteur des arts et de la culture et a
fait un certain nombre d'annoncés pour
accompagner la culture dans la reprise
pour ensuite préparer la relance
et pourquoi pas la refondation aussi
d'un certain nombre de politiques
culturelles ya notamment abordé la
question de l'avenir des artistes et des
techniciens du spectacle vivant de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma pour leur
assurer une protection pérenne sur les
mois qui viennent en prolongeant leurs
droits jusqu'à fin août 2000 21 ski
madame la députée de fête prolongera
aussi à data nivellé fameuse date
anniversaire de calcul des droits
il a aussi évoqué la question très
importante de la souveraineté culturelle
de notre pays de notre pays vous savez
que depuis plusieurs mois le
gouvernement travaille en lien avec les
autres pays européens pour se doter de
police
ambitieuse de protection des créateurs
européens et particulièrement français
c'est les directives et ses mains et
droit d'auteur que nous souhaitons le
président de la république l'a rappelé
voir transposer dans le droit français
avant la fin de l'année 2020 ce qui est
évidemment essentielle pour que les
nouveaux acteurs du numérique qui
profitent des contenus notamment des
contenus créés par les créateurs
français et européens puissent les
finances et les finances et dans les
médias et c'est la création du droit
voisin au droit d'auteur que nous avons
voté ici même il ya quelques mois et
c'est à travers cette le reste la
transposition des directives et senna et
droit d'auteur
l'obligation pour ces plateformes
d'investir dans la création française et
européenne et de respecter le droit
d'auteur à la française
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame sophie m merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la culture
monsieur le ministre
permettez moi tout d'abord d'avoir un
mot pour les personnes qui en gironde et
en particulièrement dans ma
circonscription comme dans le
département des landes qui ont été
fortement touchées par les intempéries
de ce week-end et ce début de semaine
j'adresse mes pensées aux victimes des
inondations et mes remerciements au
maire et aux élus locaux qui se sont
encore là beaucoup investie comme
toujours
monsieur le ministre le 6 mai dernier le
président de la république a consacré la
matinée à échanger avec les acteurs du
monde de la culture et annoncé plusieurs
mesures de soutien aux différents
secteurs culturels si durement éprouvée
par la crise ces annonces étaient
attendues et sont tout à fait à viser je
me félicite ainsi que mon groupe tout
particulièrement de la prolongation des
droits des intermittents du spectacle
d'une année jusqu'à la fin août 2021
elle répond à une revendication forte et
juste des intermittents qui pourront
ainsi éviter la précarité et continue à
apporter localement cette
démocratisation culturelle qui nous est
si cher
toutefois si les intermittents français
sont au nombre de 270 milles n'oublions
pas que la culture englobe plus d'un
million deux cent mille emplois
rappelons aussi que nous parlons
d'environ 3% du pib soit davantage que
les secteurs de l'automobile ou du luxe
la culture regroupe des professions
diverses dans certaines de
malheureusement dans l'incertitude ils
ne savent pas dans quelle mesure les
pouvoirs publics vont leur venir en aide
sachant pouvoir compter sur votre
implication monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous préciser les interventions
de l'état à destination des auteurs
artistes par ailleurs parmi les femmes
et les hommes qui font vivre le monde de
la culture
certains à la proche de la période
estivale attendent plus spécifiquement
des informations concernant le
patrimoine culturel pilier de notre
économie touristique
comment aider ces acteurs à valoriser
nos oeuvres et nos bâtiments en cours de
cette période si particulière
monsieur le ministre et questionnements
sont légitimes un plan de relance et de
soutien de la culture est nécessaire et
attendue tant la culture française avec
ses spécificités et belle est en chacun
de ces aspects méritent notre soutien je
vous remercie merci ministre de la
culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la député met le président de la
république la semaine dernière en plus
des annonces que je viens d'évoquer
juste avant a aussi parlé des artistes
auteurs les artistes auteurs qui sont si
essentiel dans la vie culturelle le
gouvernement dès le départ avait mis en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs
qui permettent de prendre en compte de
manière urgente des difficultés des
artistes auteurs c'est le fonds de
solidarité dont nous avons modifié en
lien avec bruno le maire les critères
d'accès pour les artistes auteurs ce
sont les dispositifs spécifiques mis en
place par les différents opérateurs du
ministère de la culture le cnc le cnm le
cnl le cnap en lien avec les
organisations de gestion collective des
droits et les professionnels pour mettre
en place des dispositifs spécifiques
d'accompagnement des artistes auteurs et
c'est les annonces donc qui viennent
d'être faites par le président de la
république qui va permettre qu'ils vont
permettre d'accompagner les artistes
auteurs dans les semaines qui viennent
notamment avec ce plan de commandes
publiques dans les différents champs
artistiques de ces artistes auteurs
notamment tourné vers les jeunes
créateurs qui va permettre de créer une
de l'activité pour ces artistes auteurs
si important non seulement à la vie
artistique notre pays mais aussi à
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
le président a eu un message très fort
pour faire en sorte qu'à partir du
moment où nous allons rouvrir nous
rouvrons
plus exactement les écoles d'une façon
différente de ce qu'elle était quand
elle était ouverte complètement va
laisser la possibilité de s'ouvrir
davantage d'activités pour l'éducation
artistique et culturelle
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin mais
aussi pendant l'été et nous travaillons
avec jean michel blanquer ainsi qu avec
roxanna maraîchine ayew et un certain
nombre d'autres collègues du
gouvernement pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions véritablement avoir
pendant ces deux mois et pendant l'été
des activités culturelles en
l'occurrence où les artistes auteurs
seraient pleinement impliqué merci
monsieur le ministre la parole tavana
mais l'info sion merci monsieur le
ministre le confinement se poursuit en
grande partie pour le monde de la
culture et de la création profondément
sinistré
nombreux sont celles et ceux à dire
l'alertent pour beaucoup c'est même un
cri de survie et il est sérieux pour la
dignité des actrices et acteurs de la
culture
il est impérieux pour nous toutes et
tous temps la culture et décisive à nos
vies les interpellations ont fini par
faire réagir emmanuel macron mais après
le show
traduisez nous monsieur le ministre le
jambon et le fromage évoquée par le
président c'est quoi exactement
qu'entendez-vous précisément par année
blanche pour les 122 milles
intermittents du spectacle artistes et
techniciens
s'agit-il uniquement de prolonger des
droits ouverts jusqu en août 2021
car dans de nombreux cas cela
n'aboutirait qu'à exclure
à cette date les intermittents qui
n'auront pas suffisamment travaillé
jusque là ce qui est demandé par le
secteur c'est un renouvellement de 12
mois tant que le calcul des heures
demeure affectée par la crise actuelle
de plus combien de mois les artistes
auteurs indépendants déclarés devront
ils tenir avec ce qui est annoncé quatre
mois huit mois 1 an et les grands
absents de ce discours ce sont les
invisibles
tout ce qui ne relève pas de
l'intermittence du spectacle mais du
régime général
bon nombre de ces intermittents de
l'emploi travail à la mission
saisonniers extra contrats courts qui
traverse cette crise grâce à leurs
indemnités chômage leur capital
d'indemnités s'épuise de jour en jour
beaucoup sont au rsa nous demandons que
soit gelé le décompte des jours jusqu'au
moment où ils pourront reprendre le
travail
ils sont au bord du précipice et pas
seulement par la crise économique qui
s'annonce mais aussi par l'application
en septembre du deuxième volet de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage dont le
retrait s'impose que prévoyez-vous après
avoir légitimement dépensé 24 milliards
d'euros pour le chômage partiel des
salariés à l'emploi stable
pourquoi faire des économies sur le dos
des salariés dont l'emploi est
discontinue des réponses précises
s'impose le risque est réel que notre
terre d'art et de culture entre en phase
d'extinction culturel
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur franck riester ministre de la
culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
faucillon je rappelle ce que je viens de
dire concernant les artistes et les
techniciens du secteur du spectacle
vivant de l'audiovisuel du cinéma qui
vont pouvoir être protégés dans les mois
qui viennent grâce à la décision qu'a
prise le président de la république de
prolonger leurs droits jusqu'au 31 août
2021 avec une prolongation de la date
anniversaire comme je viens de répondre
à madame calvaise c'est essentiel parce
que les artistes qui bénéficient de
cette de ce régime de l'intermittence et
les techniciens sont le ciment de la vie
culturelle dans notre pays est
essentielle au fonctionnement de la vie
culturelle de notre pays
concernant les autres types de régime
c'est bien évidemment en lien avec ma
collègue muriel pénicaud et sous
l'autorité du premier ministre que
progressivement un certain nombre de
décisions seront prises ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises par muriel pénicaud
dans l'hémicycle pour que
progressivement ces dispositifs très
protecteur du chômage partiel puisse
continuer d'accompagner les salariés de
ce pays
en ce qui concerne le secteur spécifique
de la culture au delà des protections
que nous devons à celles et ceux qui
travaillent dans la culture ce qui
compte c'est d'europe faire en sorte
qu'il y ait de l'activité
c'est pour ça qu'on va transposer la
directive et ses mains pour que les
plateformes investissent dans la
production audiovisuelle et
cinématographique pour permettre ensuite
d'employés
des intermittents et celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas ce statut là dans les
productions
c'est la raison pour laquelle on essaye
de trouver des solutions tout en
respectant les préconisations de
protection des de nos compatriotes en
matière sanitaire que nous puissions
progressivement réouvrir de prendre la
décision fin mai des manifestations
culturelles ou des événements culturels
que nous travaillons avec les salles de
cinéma pour peut-être dans un dans une
échéance de quelques semaines pouvoir ré
ouvrir les salles de cinéma
bref que l'activité reprenne et c'est
par l'activité que nous pourrons assurer
des rémunérations à toutes celles et
ceux qui travaillent dans le secteur de
la culture
merci monsieur le ministre la parole de
monsieur vincent rolland merci monsieur
le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état en charge du tourisme
parmi les secteurs de l'économie touchée
par la crise sanitaire
il en est un particulièrement atteints
car plus longuement confiné c'est celui
du tourisme hier véritable poumon
économique de notre pays avec près de 8%
du pib
ce secteur se retrouve peut-être plus
que les autres en grande difficulté
votre gouvernement a pris de nombreuses
mesures que nous avons voté pg un fonds
de solidarité chômage partiel annulation
de charges sociales et fiscales pendant
le confinement mais il faut aller plus
loin en prolongeant sur la période de
déconfinement les annulations de charges
sociales et fiscales en proposant des
aides directes plus importante aux
conditions d'accès assouplies pour
redonner immédiatement de l'oxygène aux
acteurs et les soutenir dans la reprise
et que dire de la situation des cafés
hôtels et restaurants ne peut-on pas
d'ores et déjà envisager leur ouverture
dans les départements vers si nous
voulons les soutenir efficacement
il est aujourd'hui primordial de revenir
un taux de tva 5 12 5% pour leur
activité en effet dans un univers
commercial dégradé avec des coûts en
augmentation
ils n'atteindront pas pour la plupart le
point mort et resteront fermées ou
disparaîtront vous l'aurez compris
monsieur le ministre sans abaissement
temporaire du taux de tva à l'instar de
ce qui s'est fait en allemagne passant
de 19 à 7 %
point de salut pour notre hôtellerie et
restauration française
alors monsieur le ministre pour ou
contre la baisse de tva 5,5
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole l'état monsieur jean-baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'europe les affaires
étrangères chargé du tourisme
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le député mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député vincent
rolland le touriste a clairement été
érigé en priorité nationale priorité
nationale et du coup nous avons agi vite
et fort dans la phase de soutien
vous l'avez dit avec l'activité
partielle avec le fonds de solidarité
avec l'accès au pge est aujourd'hui 11
12 mai nous en sommes à six milliards
d'euros de prêts garantis par l'état
garantit à 90 pour cent soixante six
mille entreprises du secteur de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration du
tourisme qui en ont bénéficié pour un
ticket moyen de 92 mille euros on voit
bien qu'on fait là justement on a
affaire à des pme des pme souvent
familiales qui se transmettent ou ou et
bien qu'ils émergent grâce au talent des
collaborateurs autour des chefs et bien
cette priorité nationale
elle va se décliner dès jeudi prochain
puisque le premier ministre présidera le
comité interministériel pour le tourisme
qui a vocation justement a bien annoncé
un certain nombre de dispositifs pour
aider les professionnels du tourisme
dans cette nouvelle phase qui va
s'ouvrir nous l'espérons très
prochainement celle d'une reprise
progressive et on sait que cette reprise
est bien elle va se faire dans des
conditions différentes de ce qui se
faisait auparavant en termes de jauge
pour respecter les protocoles sanitaires
et qui a le besoin est bien de les aider
pour trouver ce point d'équilibré
ce point mort comme on dit effectivement
dans le vocabulaire et de ce point de
vue là je peux vous dire que nous sommes
mobilisés à la tâche au travail avec
bruno le maire avec jean yves le drian
avec également les régions
pour trouver les dispositifs la palette
des outils elle vaste l'allemagne a fait
le choix de la tva mais c'est plutôt
l'allemagne qui s'aligne sur la france
puisqu'elle est passée de 19% à 7 % nous
sommes d'ores et déjà en france un taux
intermédiaire de 10% ce qui est sûr
c'est que nous serons aux côtés au
chevet des hôteliers des restaurateurs
pour que et bien ils puissent vivre
survivre dans cette période compliquée
ils sont je crois une partie de notre
adn
ils sont la france merci la parole et à
monsieur fabien lainé
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
nouveau là monsieur le secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des affaires
étrangères et donc en charge du tourisme
qui va pouvoir préciser dans son propos
sa réponse aux acteurs du tourisme
nous sommes confrontés à un virus que
nous connaissons mal et qui nous
infligent comme l'a écrit le philosophe
lucrèce l'expérience millénaire du
malheur des temps rendent dans
l'humanité assure agilité immanente à sa
vulnérabilité et à son incertitude
c'est pourquoi dans cette période
d'incertitude nous devons nous
raccrocher à la méthode scientifique qui
fonde en premier lieu sur l'expérience
l'expérimentation offre deux avantages
celui de la mise en place de mesures
progressives qui peuvent être
généralisés après évaluation et celui de
l'adaptation de ces mesures aux
particularités locales
le recours à l'expérimentation prévue
par les articles 37 et 72 de la
constitution permet de tester des
mesures de déconfinement sur le terrain
et ainsi de savoir comment organiser au
mieux un déconfinement progressif et
équilibrée entre reprise économique et
protection sanitaire
votre décision sur la réouverture des
plages en est une bonne illustration en
permettant au profit auprès fait de
l'organiser sur proposition des mères
vous avez choisi l'échelle la plus sur
l'échelle locale le déconfinement et la
reprise économique ont besoin de
confiance pour s'opérer dans de bonnes
conditions
le recours à des expérimentations
locales piloté par les maires permet
d'évaluer l'efficacité des mesures et de
les adapter aux différentes situations
locales et ainsi de créer les conditions
de la confiance
en s'appuyant sur la connaissance des
élus le secteur du tourisme au sens
large a beaucoup souffert du confinement
il aura besoin d'une reprise efficace
tant ce
le plan sanitaire qu'économique vendredi
vous annoncerez les mesures spécifiques
à ce secteur
comptez vous vous appuyer sur les
expérimentations locales pour mettre en
oeuvre le déconfinement comment allez
vous associer les collectivités locales
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur jean baptiste de moine
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe des affaires étrangères chargé
du tourisme
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député l'association des
élus locaux nous l'avons souhaité depuis
le début pour pouvoir faire face avec
eux à cette crise qui a touché de plein
fouet le secteur du tourisme
cette association des élus locaux nous
le faisions avec jean yves le drian dans
le cadre du comité de pilotage du
tourisme nous le faisons dans le cadre
du également du comité de filière et
donc chaque semaine c'est un véritable
retour d'expérience que nous avons grâce
aux témoignages des élus témoignages qui
se décline également dans le tour de
france des régions et des territoires
que nous avons conduits et notamment
avec annick girardin à la rencontre des
territoires ultra marins mais aussi avec
un certain nombre de territoires
présentant des spécificités vous évoquez
la réouverture des plages et hier avec
jacqueline gourault justement nous
avions une réunion avec à la fois l'anel
à la fois l'anem pour et bien travaillé
à cette reprise travailler tout
simplement à ce que et bien dans les
semaines qui suivent les français
puissent redécouvrir la france si les
conditions sanitaires permettent puisse
explorer ces territoires est très
clairement c'est ce couple élu local et
à qui permettra à cette filière de
redémarrer
c'est le cas lorsque il y à un dialogue
pour la réouverture des petits musées
des petits sites et monuments est d'ores
et déjà il ya une offre finalement
nature et culture qui dans les
départements vers vous le signalez
commencent à se faire jour et permet et
bien aux français de prendre ce bol
d'air si important après les événements
un peu traumatique que nous avons vécu
donc je vous le confirme c'est avec les
élus locaux que nous allons également
bâtir ce grand plan de relance et de
transformation du tourisme que le
premier ministre présentera
au comité interministériel de jeudi
matin le président des régions de france
renaud muselier
il travaillait ce matin même avec l'état
pour avoir les bons dispositif en
matière de tourisme social en matière
d'investissement donc oui c'est un
partenariat très étroit avec les élus
locaux et avec la représentation
nationale naturellement merci monsieur
le ministre la parole à monsieur eric
straumann
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse ce
premier ministre tout à l'heure le
ministre de la santé des solidarités da
pas répondu à la question aux questions
d'olivier belges qui étaient précises
il a évoqué le département du haut rhin
on nous expliquait qu'on trouve des
masques en nombre on en trouve ni en
pharmacie ni en grande surface beaucoup
de masques sont bloqués dans nos
frontières et aux services de douanes il
a posé la question de la certification
de ces masses qui sont fabriqués
localement par le pôle textile alsace
est aujourd'hui pour de sombres raisons
bureaucratiques
on n'obtient pas cette certification
donc il ne s'agit pas de la question de
l'importation des des masques
ma question est plus précise et
d'ailleurs le ministre a évoqué c'est
vrai qu'on a passé le taux de tva des
masques de 20 à 5 5%
mais enfin ces masques aujourd'hui même
s'il était inutile il ya encore quelques
semaines sont aujourd'hui devenus un
outil absolument indispensable je dirais
même vitale alors moi je constate qu en
autriche on applique aujourd'hui un taux
de tva à de tva 2 0 en fait il ya une
exonération complète de la tva en
autriche et l'italie et l'espagne vont
aller dans cette direction
alors on nous a expliqué puisque les
républicains avaient fait sept premiers
cette proposition en commission de
finances d'exonérer les masques et les
moyens de protection de la tva on nous a
expliqué que c'est bruxelles qui était
contre que c'était contraire au droit
communautaire
j'ai interrogé une collègue députée
européenne qui m'a dit qu'aujourd'hui la
commission européenne avait décidé de ne
pas interpeller les pays qui exonérait
les masques de ce taux de tva donc
caisse pourquoi ce qui est possible en
autriche en italie et en espagne ne
l'est pas c'est possible chez nous et
pour terminer mon collègue belge tu as
quand même rappeler un kit de masques et
vendu dans un débit de tabac 100 euros
ba 5 1 5 euros d'économies pour une
famille c'est important dans le coup
dans la conjoncture actuelle merci merci
chers collègues la parole est à madame
agnès pannier rina chez secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député je promène
permettez moi tout d'abord de rappeler
une chose assez simple et qui finalement
ne permet pas de passer trop de temps
sur la tva c'est que près d'un masque
sur deux en france et distribué par
l'état gratuitement 100 millions de
masques pour les soignants dans les
hôpitaux dans les ehpad dans les
pharmacies 100 millions par semaine et
je veux rajouter à ces 100 millions les
20 millions de masques lavables
réutilisables 20 fois ce qui équivaut à
420 millions de masques à usage unique
qui vont à destination des écoles des
agents publics et des plus précaires ça
c'est la réalité du marché français près
d'un masque sur deux distribués
gratuitement
le reste des masses sont désormais
depuis la date du déconfinement le 11
mai librement accessibles dans un
certain nombre de points de vente
ils sont effectivement la tva réduite à
5 5% et nous n'avons pas nécessairement
la même interprétation d'une note
interservices de la commission
européenne que nous avons interprété
comme nous autorisant à m le taux de tva
à 5 5% soit le taux le plus bas de notre
système de tva
ce taux est applicable depuis le 24 mars
ce n'est pas le cas en autriche
aujourd'hui ce taux sera applicable
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 je crois
savoir qu en autriche ce sera jusqu'au
31 juillet de 2021 pardon je crois
savoir qu en autriche et jusqu'au 31
juillet de cette année vous voyez
finalement nous ne sommes pas s'ils
viennent mal lotis en france l'important
c'est que l'ensemble des français aient
accès à ces masques de protection
massivement qui leur soit fournie soit
par l'état soit par leur employeur comme
c'est le cas dans l'essentiel des cas
d'équipement et que pour les reste ils
aient accès à des masques de qualité qui
soit effectivement mis à leur
disposition manière
et itif c'est ce que fait aujourd'hui la
grande distribution les pharmaciens à
des coudes usage de 20 à 30 centimes je
vous remercie
merci madame fabienne colboc
merci monsieur le président j'associe à
cette question mes deux collègues
françois cormier boli gens et cédric
roussel
madame la ministre des sports la crise
sanitaire entrave aujourd'hui la
pratique des activités sportives mais à
l'arrêt des championnats les
championnats et remet en cause la
viabilité d'un véritable écosystème
fédérations associations sportives clubs
professionnels mais également employeurs
et entreprises du sport dans le cadre du
groupe de travail sur la gestion de la
crise dans les domaines des sports et de
la vie associative que j'anime avec
régis juanico nous auditionnons les
acteurs et tous saluent l'accompagnement
de vos services et les mesures prises
par l'état
la circulaire du 6 mai qui sécurise
l'attribution des subventions promises
par l'état aux associations étaient
également très attendu ma question
portera sur les clubs amateurs et la
reprise progressive de la pratique
sportive
les clubs amateurs sont inquiets au
sujet de la pérennité de leur modèle
socio-économique l'épuisement des
trésoreries
la baisse envisagée du mécénat la
crainte des pertes de licencier l'aide
différencier des fédérations et des
collectivités territoriales
une crainte existe aussi sur
l'indisponibilité temporaire des
bénévoles indispensables à la vie des
clubs
les clubs sont également en attente de
la date de reprise à la normale de leurs
activités sportives
le plan stratégique de déconfinement
progressive présenté par le premier
ministre permet depuis hier une reprise
de certaines pratiques en expert en
extérieur avec des conditions bien
définies
c'est une bonne chose pour préserver
l'élan sportif des français que nous
avons pu observer durant le confinement
il permet aussi aux équipements pour
l'entraînement des sportifs qui permet
aussi l'accès aux équipements pour
l'entraînement des sportifs
professionnels et pour la reprise
d'activités à caractère scolaires et
périscolaires notamment avec le
dispositif deux aces de ces qui est à
développer à préciser pour qui permettra
aux enfants d'exercer une activité
sportive ou culturelle dans le cadre de
la reprise scolaire la pratique la
pratique sportive est essentielle
madame la ministre comment faire
perdurer cet élan sportif et relancer
les clubs amateurs forces vives sur les
terrils
dans quelle mesure lagence national du
sport pourra-t-elle répondre aux enjeux
évoqués
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
roxana maracineanu ministre des sports
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la fabienne colboc vous avez
pleinement raison de dire que cette
période vient de démontrer la place
qu'occupe le sport dans nos vies
personnelles comme dans notre vie
collective
pourtant la crise que subit le sport
français est grave et c'est pour cela
que nous protégeons et soutenons le
sport à tous les étages car l'esprit de
responsabilité dont ont fait preuve tous
les acteurs sportifs méritent d'être
soulignées à commencer par nos sportifs
de haut niveau
très actif sur les réseaux sociaux pour
rappeler le bon comportement à tenir
pendant le confinement mais aussi les
clubs et les dirigeants des instances
sportives je veux remercier aussi
l'engagement des agents du ministère au
niveau central territoriales comme dans
nos établissements
vous évoquez le rôle de l' agence
nationale du sport son soutien du sport
français mais surtout sa gouvernance
partagée une gouvernance ouverte aux
acteurs sportifs aux collectivités et au
monde économique qui a été le terreau de
notre unité d'action dans la période
efficace pendant la crise elle sera
indispensable pour imaginer les
politiques sportives de demain adapté
aux besoins et aux réalités de chaque
territoire et de chaque français
le risque pour le sport est celui de
l'affaiblissement durable de nos clubs
avec une reprise des bénévoles comme des
pratiquants qui restent en suspens comme
vous l'avez mentionné le travail pour un
plan de relance globale et coordonnée et
déjà engagé avec tous nos partenaires au
sein du gouvernement avec jean michel
blanquer r nous avons engagé nos
ministères et le mouvement sportif dans
le dispositif sport santé culture
civisme les éducateurs sportifs de nos
clubs apporteront leur aide aux élus
locaux en appui à la réouverture des
classes ce dispositif permet d'agrandir
la surface d'accueil des enfants et de
mettre en face des enfants des adultes
compétents et diplômés en nombre
suffisant pour fonctionner par petits
groupes c'est une étape très importante
pour le projet que je partage avec jean
michel blanquer ce projet de continuité
éducative entre les lieux d'accueil des
enfants l'école et le monde associatif
dans la continuité nous avons aussi un
projet de vacances à prenantes
avec gabriel attal julien de normandie
franck riester et jean michel blanquer
avec la mise en place d'une offre
associative et de renforcement scolaire
avec des activités sportives variées
pour cet été le sport repartira grâce à
l'investissement de toutes et tous et je
sais pouvoir compter sur vous merci
madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur oublie des
libérables merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre je
rentre de ma circonscription du maghreb
d'afrique de l'ouest
et je voudrais vous alerter la situation
est grave il y a encore des milliers de
français qui sont bloqués nabil atteints
de la maladie de parkinson qui est sans
soins ambre une petite fille de 3 ans
qui pleure tous les jours parce qu'elle
est arrachée à sa maman bloqués à
l'étranger au maroc
chantal une femme véhiculée bloqués au
maroc dans le sud du pays qui ont monté
à maintes reprises dans le nord pour
prendre un bateau qu'elle n'a pas pu
prendre
il y à monsieur le ministre de la colère
il ya de la souffrance
il y a de la déchirure alors parce
qu'une grande majorité d'entre eux sont
des binationaux
ils ont le sentiment d'être oubliés ils
ont le sentiment que la france leur
tourner le dos alors combien de français
reste-t-il encore bloqués monsieur le
ministre quel dispositif spécifique
quel plan de rapatriement pour toutes
celles et ceux qui depuis des mois sont
loin de leur maison
vous nous proposez merci monsieur le
ministre merci j'ai débuté la parole est
à monsieur jean yves le drian ministre
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
le guerrab vous vous connaissez la
situation au maghreb les autorités
marocaines algériennes tunisiennes ont
fermé leur espace aérien pour des
raisons sanitaires
nous respectons ces décisions comme il
respecte les nôtres les autorités en
question ont demandé à leurs compagnies
de ne plus assurer de vol
nous respectons ces décisions et
au cours de la dernière période nous
avons permis le retour je prends le cas
du maroc en particulier puisque c'était
le cas le plus spectaculaire de 30 mille
de nos ressortissants qui étaient pour
des raisons familiales ou des raisons de
vacances ou des raisons professionnelles
au maroc par le biais de dérogation au
vol par vol par nos compagnies par
l'action du ministère des transports par
l'action du secrétaire d'état jean
baptiste lemoyne par l'action de aussi
du soutien d'air france nous avons pu
faire en sorte que trente mille de nos
compatriotes reviennent
merci de côte de le reconnaître trente
mille rien que pour le maroc
alors il reste il reste monsieur le
député des français résidant en france
mais passant généralement du temps au
maroc en surtout en algérie en tunisie
au cours de l'année ceux là sont
aujourd'hui effectivement en difficulté
et nous avons décidé d'augmenter le
nombre de vols de la compagnie nationale
air france pour permettre leur retour
nous avons aussi décidé de mettre en
oeuvre des bateaux qui n'a aujourd'hui
qui va de tanger med à 7 pour permettre
le retour d'un certain nombre de camping
caristes comme l'ont dit mais je sais
que cette question existent mais elles
existent dans le cadre de contraintes
sanitaires que nous devons respecter
nous sommes en mobiliser pour aboutir à
a doublé le nombre de fréquences pour le
maroc et pour les pays du maghreb en
direction de la france mais à ceux faits
par nos propres moyens ou par le biais
de relations aériennes affrétées donc
notre mobilisation est totale mais les
contraintes sanitaires de cépie là aussi
merci monsieur le ministre
seul le but des mets merci monsieur le
ministre et par votre biais je salue
l'action de tous nos postes consulaires
qui font un travail exceptionnel je les
ai vus sur le terrain et nous avons la
chance d'avoir à la puissance de ce
réseau consulaire qui personne par
personne fait monter nos compatriotes
dans les avions
mais monsieur le ministre je je je vous
le dis il faut aller plus loin il faut
faire
plus vite il faut aller encore plus fort
le travail monsieur le ministre n'est
pas finie faut plus d'avion plus de gros
porteurs il faut plus de bateaux plus de
solutions parce qu'aujourd'hui
comme je le disais de la souffrance
il y en a et de la souffrance
psychologique elle est en train de se
transformer en souffrance physique
merci monsieur le ministre merci madame
danielle obono vous avez la parole
selon un sondage publié par libération
le 31 mars
84% des personnes interrogées appellent
de leurs voeux la relocalisation en
europe d'un maximum des filières de
production 69% veulent ralentir le
productivisme et la recherche
perpétuelle de rentabilité 88% réclame
un accès à l'eau et à un air de qualité
et 76% à la biodiversité
le 9 mai dernier une autre enquête
d'opinion publiée dans le jdd indique
encore que pour le monde d'après la
protection de l'environnement fait
partie des thèmes jugés prioritaires
pour une majorité de la population avec
la santé l'éducation les services
publics la crise sanitaire a encore
élargi la prise de conscience de ce que
devraient être nos priorités pour une
majorité de la population
l'épidémie de kovy 19 nous rappelle
cruellement les désordres écologiques
provoqués par la globalisation
néolibérale la déforestation massive
l'élevage intensif l'ultra densification
urbaine sont autant de facteurs qui ont
concouru à la transmission du virus aux
humains et à sa propagation
ce moment doit être l'occasion d'une
véritable bifurcation écologique et
solidaire
les français et françaises l'ont bien
compris mais de toute évidence pas ce
gouvernement
le grand blabla jupitérien cache mal les
indigences stratégique de votre anti
politique écologique refus d'instaurer
des conditions sociales et
environnementales au soutien financier
aux grandes entreprises parmi les plus
polluantes soutien à l'accord de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et le
mexique qui dérégule le marché d'énergie
des matières premières et de
l'agriculture silence complice sur
l'avis favorable donné un projet de
montagne d'orbis en guyane qui implique
une déforestation massive et une
pollution irréversible des sols j'en
passe et des pires la milice sens et de
s'occuper de toutes ces questions est
passé en mode fantôme
peut-être est-ce dû à sa totale
incompétence sur ces sujets ou de
l'incurie systémique des plus hauts
sommets de la macro ni alors monsieur le
premier ministre
quelle est exactement la stratégie de
transition écologique ou ce qui
ressemble dans votre univers que vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre avec quels
moyens et quel objectif précis merci
madame le député la parole en vrai à
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire
madame elisabeth bornes merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée au bono
permettez moi de dire les choses très
clairement en matière d'écologie
je préfère l'action au discours
déconnecté des réalités
c'est la ligne que je tiens à la tête de
mon ministère et c'est la ligne que
j'applique depuis le début de cette
crise j'agis en ne cédant rien aux
demandes de retour en arrière sur les
normes environnementales
j'ai refusé tout moratoire la france a
dit non à une remise en question du
green deal européen
il n'y aura pas de pause en matière de
transition écologique et j'agis en
accélérant notre calendrier écologique
j'en veux pour preuve le forfait
mobilité durable qui est une avancée
porté par cette majorité le gouvernement
à accélérer la mise en oeuvre dès le
week end dernier pour aider des millions
de salariés et d'agents publics qui se
rendent au travail en voiture ou en
partant au covoiturage ou un vélo c'est
des mesures concrètes qui change le
quotidien des français et madame la
députée au bono est ce que vous avez le
souvenir d'un gouvernement qui en temps
de crise aurait associé le sauvetage
d'une entreprise un plan de
transformation écologique
nous nous le faisons avec air france
nous éditons la faillite de la compagnie
mais dans le même temps nous obtenons un
engagement historique de réduction
drastique des vols sur les trajets ayant
une alternative ferroviaire en moins de
2h30
je le dis enfin jarlan ce que nous
préparons sera durable nous allons créer
des emplois dans la rénovation thermique
dans la mobilité électrique dans les
énergies renouvelables
ne rien céder accélérez portée des
transformations concrètes
voilà notre ligne voilà la réponse de
cette majorité au défi écologique
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur rémy rebeyrotte la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre nous
voulons d'abord vous remercier d'avoir
avancé le rendu du rapport du conseil
scientifique permettant d'installer dans
les meilleurs délais plus de 30000
conseils municipaux complet issu du
scrutin du 15 mars dernier
une fois de plus vous avez su écouter
des élus locaux qui dans le nouveau
contexte du déconfinement souhaité que
les nouvelles équipes s'installent au
plus vite les uns pour pouvoir se mettre
au travail
les autres pour tourner une page qui
n'est jamais simple à tourner au premier
nous adressons nos félicitations pour
leur élection au second nos
remerciements les plus sincères pour les
services rendus à la république de
proximité remerciements d'autant plus
appuyé qu'ils ont dû gérer sur le
terrain dans leur commune la crise
sanitaire majeure que nous connaissons
dans sa dimension confinement est sorti
de confinement vous avez annoncé
l'installation des nouveaux conseils
issus du premier tour entre le 23 et le
28 mai prochain
pourriez vous nous préciser les
conditions dans lesquelles pourra se
faire cette installation est la suite de
celle ci concernant la gestion des
intercommunalités dans la tente du
second tour des élections dans les 5000
communes qui n'auront de conseils
municipaux complet et lui qu'à l'issue
du second tour
merci monsieur le premier ministre merci
chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député et rebeyrotte
merci pour votre question et je voudrais
m'associer à ce que vous avez indiquée
en terme
message à adresser à tous ses élus
locaux qui se sont présentés aux
suffrages de leurs concitoyens
le 15 mars dernier certains ont été élus
il faut évidemment les féliciter
d'autres ont été battus soit qu' il se
présentait afin d'être à nouveau réélu
et ils ont été battus soit parce que nos
concitoyens ne leur ont pas fait
confiance et je voudrais profiter de
l'occasion que vous me donnez pour dire
que se présenter aux suffrages de ses
concitoyens c'est un acte démocratique
important que parfois on parfois on
gagne parfois ce n'est pas le cas mais
se présentait une élection démocratique
dire que l'on veut assumer une partie de
la responsabilité publique et de
l'administration de la commune c'est
toujours un acte démocratique un choix
démocratique individuelles bien sûr
c'est souvent une aventure collective
mais quelque chose de très fort et
qu'indépendamment des résultats tous
ceux qui en france nos concitoyens porte
cette volonté de participer à la gestion
d'une commune font honneur à la
démocratie et à la république vous
l'avez dit monsieur le député vous
l'avez fait pendant longtemps et je veux
les remercier à ce micro
trente mille cent trente neuf communes
dans trente mille cent trente neuf
communes les électeurs de notre pays ont
élu une équipe municipale complète elle
n'a pas encore pu prendre ses fonctions
elles n'ont pas encore pu prendre ses
fonctions il faut donc pouvoir leur
permettre de s'installer délire
définitivement le maire et ses adjoints
et de pouvoir commencer le travail
je vous l'avais dit monsieur le député
sollicité l'avis du conseil scientifique
le 4 mai cet avis a été rendu le 8 mai
j'ai transmis ce matin le 12 mai le
rapport rédigé sur la base de cet avis
aux présidents des deux assemblées et le
conseil scientifique concluant que
l'élection des exécutifs locaux peut se
tenir sous réserve bien entendu de se
dérouler dans un lieu adapté de limiter
le nombre de personnes présentes et de
respecter les règles sanitaires
notamment les distances municipal et
dispense municipal les distances
minimales pardon il est possible de
procéder dans de bonnes conditions à
l'installation des conseils municipaux
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure je veux leur
dire nous avions avec le parlement
adapter les règles de fonctionnement des
institutions locales aux exigences du
contexte sanitaire deux ordonnances sur
le fondement des dispositions de la
loire ont déjà été adoptés en ce sens la
première le 1er avril et la deuxième le
8 avril dernier une nouvelle ordonnance
sera délibéré en conseil des ministres
demain le 13 mai et publié jeudi
le 14 mai elle adaptera les règles de
quorum et de présence du public de façon
à rendre possible conformément
d'ailleurs aux indications du conseil
scientifique les règles applicables
nous pourrons donc dans ces conditions
organisez l'installation des conseils
municipaux j'ai indiqué quel serait le
calendrier le décret sera publié le
vendredi 15 mai la date d'entrée en
fonction des conseillers municipaux et
communautaires et communautaire sera
fixée au lundi 18 mai conformément à la
loi du 23 mars
la première réunion du conseil municipal
qui permettra notamment d'élire le maire
et ses adjoints
mais également le vote des délégations
au maire les représentants dans les
commissions d'appels d'offres ce qui est
très important pour pouvoir faire
repartir l'activité dans de bonnes
conditions
tout ça pourrait être fait entre le
samedi 23 mai et le jeudi 28 mai il
reste un mot à dire sur ce sujet puisque
au delà des 30 mille cent soixante 139
commune 30130 neuf communes qui ont été
directement élu au premier tour il y à
105 à 154 conseil communautaire qui sont
entièrement constituée dès le premier
tour
154 conseil communautaire entièrement
constituée dès le premier tour
cela se réuniront plus tard le 8 juin
2020 c'est-à-dire trois semaines après
leur date d'entrée en fonction et ils
pourront dans le cadre de ce calendrier
élire leur exécutif voilà monsieur le
député ce que je voulais dire
précisément réponse à votre question
pour le reste je les dis nous allons
attendre l'avis du conseil scientifique
et sur le fondement de cet avis nous
pourrons réfléchir collectivement et
prendre une décision sur la possibilité
de tenir le second tour des élections
municipales
je vous remercie monsieur le député
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
science des questions au gouvernement
est terminée je vous remercie de sortir
de manière échelonnée prochaine séance
demain à 15h lecture définitive de la
proposition de loi relative à la lutte
contre les contenus haineux sur internet
la séance est levée